So Leute, auf geht's.
Oh, Teams hat meinen Sound wieder
verstellt. MonkaS.
So ein Kack-Tool. Ich reg mich da jeden Tag
drüber auf.
Geht ja eigentlich gar nicht so wild.
Aber ich hör das sofort, dass Teams
da irgendwie dran rumgesaut hat.
Excellent, excellent.
So.
Po-Girls.
Auf geht's.
Heute riecht Shagaman wieder.
Massive Hackermans.
Oh, ich glaube, ich sollte mal, bevor ich hier rumrenne
gleich im Zimmer und die
Switcher auspacke, sollte ich vielleicht erstmal
mein Headset ein bisschen entknoten.
Ja, passt.
So, erstmal warten,
bis der Stream on ist.
Oh Mist, ich hab ne, ich seh's grad,
ich hab hier so ne Falte im Teppich.
Da roll ich jetzt jedes Mal mit dem Stuhl drüber.
Das sackt.
Das müsste ich mal irgendwie da gerade machen.
Aber hier ist grad eh so viel
umgerollt.
Und sonst was. Ihr werdet auch gleich ein bisschen
Kabelsalat sehen. Zumindest am Rand sieht man, glaube ich,
ein bisschen Kabelsalat.
Moin. Müssen wir mal gucken, wie ich die,
mal gucken, ob ich die Kamera richtig eingestellt hab, Leute.
Ob man, ob man den Kabelsalat
äh,
ja, ein bisschen, ein bisschen.
Bisschen Kabelsalat sieht man hier unten an der Seite.
Di-di-di-di-di.
Fingerleak.
MonkaS.
Finger.
Da ist er.
Original.
MaxSauce Finger.
Hat man im Stream schon öfters gesehen.
Boomer Finger hier.
Bu-Bu-Boomer Finger.
Zwei Boomer Finger.
Chris Stonehenge, 16 Monate.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge Subscriptions hier wieder.
Die Azubi-Chit-Rebo, die hab ich doch schon
50 Mal im Stream erzählt.
Aber, wenn du's noch nicht kennst, dann
musst du aufs Video warten.
Vielleicht erzähl ich doch,
im Laufe des Abends auch noch mal,
wenn's mir danach ist.
CloudSwitch.
Ja, Poggas.
Ja, mal ein bisschen ausprobieren.
So sieht's aus.
Müssen wir die Emotes ein bisschen mehr verwenden?
Wir haben jetzt, wir haben jetzt so viele
nice Emotes,
die
ich mir nicht anzeigen lassen kann,
weil ich eingeloggt bin.
Pazip.
Moin.
Nice Twitch Prime Subscription.
Huge.
IQ Upgrade.
Was ist denn ein CloudSwitch?
Ein CloudSwitch ist was, wo MikroTik
einfach einen geilen Namen draufschreiben will.
10G-Incoming.
Na, ich hab ja schon 10G.
10G.
Okay, Leute.
Wir raten jetzt mal.
Was ist das, was ich hier in...
Was ich
ins Bild halte?
Wer errät's? Wir machen jetzt mal
Massive Quiz.
Jetzt steht's sogar drauf.
Lul, weh.
Man hat sogar erkannt, was es ist.
Hentai Tentakel. Nein, das ist falsch.
Und Cock ist es auch nicht.
Das ist das Raspberry Pi 4 Case.
Richtig.
Machen wir mal was anderes.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
ob ihr das erratet.
Moment, Moment.
Erstmal was Schwieriges.
Erstmal die schwierige Variante.
Was ist das?
Es ist nicht
Jepp Cock. So viel kann ich schon mal verraten.
Messer.
Ahhhhh.
Meint ihr immer noch, dass es ein Messer ist?
Richtig.
Korrekt.
Das ist der einzig wahre
Abisoliert-Champ.
Ihr habt's ja richtig erkannt.
Der ist natürlich auch am Start.
Den brauchen wir heute Abend allerdings nicht, weil heute Abend gibt's nichts zum Abisolieren.
Aber der muss immer mit dabei sein.
Der Abisoliert-Champ.
Beste.
Finger ab.
Da ist er.
ist easy das ist easy das ist das erkennt ihr sofort also jeder das schon
mal gesehen erkennt an den farben was das zeitenschneider genau richtig
zeitenschneider ok genug quiz champ würde ich sagen oder doch doch doch
warte mal warte mal ein ein quiz champ machen wir noch weil er wisst ihr nicht
was es ist faktisch steht drauf was es ist das schlecht das kann ich nicht
zeigen ich will jetzt noch ein quiz champ machen ein quiz champ was was was
was was machen wir da jetzt ok da kommt ihr nicht drauf da kommt ihr nicht drauf
außer die im stream dabei was ist das oh guck mal wenn ich mit dem fuß auf die
erde dingse dann wackelt die kamera exzellent das ist kein usb stick nein
auch kein powerlogger usb powermeter
5g
das ist einfach einen usb relay du kannst damit usb geräte remote an und
ausschalten hier kannst du den knopf drücken dann wird das usb gerät an und
ausgeschaltet oder du kannst es ins wlan hängen da ist nämlich ein sp 32 glaube
ich drauf und du kannst über das wlan usb geräte ein und ausschalten
das kann man nicht erraten wenn man nicht zufällig mal im stream dabei
gewesen ist das geht nicht so ich zeige euch jetzt mal kurz bevor wir richtig
loslegen mal die switcher die ich gekauft habe
habe war also ich habe einmal den hier am start und also die musik muss man
kamer wechseln ja das können doch gleich schon deutlich fröhlich hier kannst du
mal link in excel und c sharp zertifizierung machen weil die sowas ich
soll jetzt auf der arbeit los sich ärger eher schulungen machen mein sch conséquens Thrille
bei excursus
schulung machen mein schef pengant pdf geschickt ПО РАЗ У РУ Unkountable physiology
hat mir heute ein PDF geschickt, mit
jetzt ohne Scheiß, ich hab nicht gezählt,
aber ich würde sagen 300 Escher-Schulungen, hat gemeint,
ja, such mal aus.
Da hab ich gesagt, äh, ich weiß überhaupt nicht,
um was es da geht, die meisten Wörter sagen mir noch
nix.
Was soll ich mir da aussuchen? Ja, such dir mal irgendwas aus,
ist egal. Gut, hab ich mir irgendwas
ausgesucht, ja.
LinkedIn-Zertifikate, ernsthaft?
Wär das nicht ein bisschen klein?
Nennst du es der Switch oder
die Switch? Äh, der
Switch.
Oder den Switch?
Die?
Passt irgendwie in dem Fall nicht, oder?
Also die Konsole, die Konsole
ist die Switch
und der Netzwerkswitch ist der
Switch. Also komplett Gleichberechtigung
gibt die Switch und der Switch.
Die Nintendo Switch und der Netzwerkswitch,
genau.
So sieht's aus. So.
Und Switch
innen, das könnte man auch machen, ja.
Manchmal,
manchmal, manchmal
irritiert mich das ja ein bisschen.
Wie ihr wisst davon, ich bin Fan, dass jeder machen kann, was er will.
Aber manche Twitch-Profile,
Twitch-Profile, äh, nicht Twitch, ähm,
Twitter-Profile irritieren mich doch,
wenn ich da reingucke. Es ist ja so
im Trend, dass man in sein Twitter-Profil
oben reinschreibt, wie man angesprochen werden will.
Das ist ja in der heutigen Zeit auch gut, weil
es ist ja nicht mehr so
auf den ersten Blick oftmals erkennbar.
So. Und da stehen dann manchmal so Sachen
drin, wie, äh,
dass jemand innen,
innen, keine Ahnung, einen Wolf ist
oder sowas, wo ich mir dann so denke, äh,
what? Da blick ich dann nicht mehr
durch, Alter. Das hört's dann auf
bei mir. Und ein Lama
oder so hab ich sogar schon mal gesehen.
Naja.
Gut, aber wie gesagt, jeder wie er will.
Wo plan? Sieben Monate
Massive IQ Explosion. Nein, kein
Dark Mode. Ich mach auch kein Dark Mode
an, weil ich hab hier die
übelst fette Beleuchtung am Start. Wenn ich Dark Mode
anmach, guck ich auf den Monitor
und erst mal Dark Mode, dann guck ich
später in das Elgato Ring Light
Instant Blind.
So.
Also. Einmal haben wir das Ding am Start.
Das ist ein
4-Port-10G-Switch
mit
einem 1G-PoE-Port.
Und das da
ist ein 8-Port-
1G-Switch
und, Alter, die Bilder sind ja mal wieder
massive, massive Suck, Alter.
Ah, nein, nein, ich will nicht Map,
ich will Bilder, Bilder, nicht Images.
Und zwei 10G-Ports.
Warum kein Cisco-Router?
Gibst du mir Geld, dann kauf ich mir Cisco-Router.
Kann man alles machen.
Kann man aber auch sein lassen.
Außerdem, außerdem, Cisco, Cisco,
wenn es Cisco ist, dann ist es definitiv ein Router.
Bist du auf Windows oder Linux?
Wenn das Windows ist,
verwirrt mich die schnelle Linux-Performance.
Das ist, der Haus ist Windows,
der Haus ist Windows, siehst du auch hier in den Windows-Desktops.
Na, zack.
Das ist Windows.
Und ich hab einfach auf dem zweiten Desktop
eine VM. Guck hier.
Linux-VM auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Mit, ganz wichtig, wer seine
VM nicht mit FPS-Anzeige
betreibt,
verliert FPS.
Also, ihr müsst unbedingt, also das allerwichtigste
ist, dass man in der VM weiß, wie schnell
man die Maus gerade bewegt in FPS.
Ansonsten ist das einfach low-brain.
Hm.
So, das hab ich am Start.
Dann hab ich noch, falls wir brauchen,
falls wir brauchen, hab ich auch noch
nen ollen,
nen ollen, äh,
drei, Raspberry Pi 3 am Start.
Also, hier, da.
Exquisite.
Aber ich glaub, den brauchen wir nicht.
Ich glaub, der Vierer, der da hinten, der
ecklig, der, der reicht jetzt erstmal.
Und ich hab's nicht hingekriegt, diesen
komischen Treiber für die, für die Netzwerkkarte
zu installieren. Also, ich zeig, ich zeig mal kurz was.
Also, ich zeig, ich zeig mal kurz was.
Also, hier haben wir nen Raspberry Pi 4
mit, äh,
hier, guck mal.
Richtig, richtig Boom erhemmt.
Muss ja, muss ja auch passen.
Programm hier. Also, ich hab hier zum Test
ein paar Sachen am Start. Ich zeig euch das mal.
Dazu muss ich allerdings aufstehen,
weil, ähm, ich hab das, ich hab das
hier ein bisschen, das Setup ein bisschen höher gebaut.
Und wenn ich jetzt nicht aufstehe,
dann komm ich nicht richtig dran.
Ich muss noch meinen Stuhl wegschieben.
Das heißt, ich muss mich immer mal zwischendrin umdrehen für nen Chat.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt mal kurz was nicht
sehe, dann...
Dann seh ichs halt kurz nicht.
Also, ich zeig euch mal kurz was wir am Start haben.
Und zwar, wir haben einmal...
Leute, ich brauch unbedingt hier neben irgendwie
so ne Vorschau. Ich brauch unbedingt
so ne Vorschau für den Stream.
Ich überleg grad.
Oh, Leute, ich hab, ich hab ne massive
Brain-Idee. Ich hol jetzt mein Tablet.
Ich hol mein Tablet und mach die Stream-Vorschau
drauf an. Wartet mal, wartet mal, ich bin gleich wieder da.
So, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich muss jetzt nochmal auf dem Tablet das Ganze aufmachen.
Äh, Tablet.
Ich brauch nämlich den Invite-Link.
By the way, den Invite-Link müsst ihr nicht ausprobieren, der geht extern nicht.
Chrome
aufmachen.
Und jetzt, wie, wie ist die Adresse? Moment.
viewft...
Ach, du große Scheiße.
Der denkt nicht so'n Kack aus.
Hallo, Tablet, please funktionieren.
Lass mir den ganzen Müll zumachen, der da noch läuft.
Hätte ich schon vorher machen sollen, aber...
Ich brauch ne Vorschau.
Static...
OBS
Ninja...
Und jetzt...
Brauchen wir
was?
F...
T7...
T...
C...
Okay, und jetzt sollte der Mist auf dem Tablet aufgehen, hoffe ich,
dass ich's richtig gemacht hab.
Ja, Chat, I'm in, ist klar, ist klar, ist klar.
Okay, nice. Und jetzt muss ich mal gucken...
Muss ich das jetzt, muss ich das
so hinstellen, dass ich mich nicht leake, Leute.
Not, not leaked.
So, dass ich mich nicht,
nicht, nicht leake.
So.
Seh ich jetzt hier was gescheit? Und jetzt hier...
Excellent, excellent.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt seh ich nämlich so ungefähr, was ich mache, ja?
So, so, so, so, so der Spur nach.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier was
nehme und zeig das in die Kamera,
dann kann ich auf dem Vorschau gucken,
ob die, ob die Kamera das, das, das
richtig fokussiert und macht. Das ist schon mal
ganz gut.
Leaked.
So, also. Hosenleaked.
Oh ne, stimmt, Hose, Hose ist geleaked. Shit.
Hose ist gele...
Wo, wo ist, war hier, war hier grad das Hosenleaked?
Da, Hosenleaked? Ne.
MonkaS.
Haare leaked?
Also ich hab Haare leaked?
Wie soll ich denn Haare geleaked haben?
So, kann ich das vielleicht noch ein bisschen
schräg machen, dass ich auch was seh?
Oder kann ich's hochkant machen oder so?
Hat man das sackt.
Ich probier das mal hochkant aus.
Hochkant besser?
Seh ich da jetzt mehr?
Ja, okay, okay, ist besser, ist besser.
Also, ähm.
Tja, mit was fangen wir jetzt mal an, Leute?
Cockleek.
Das wär's jetzt, da wär ich schon instant
bunt, Alter.
So, ähm.
Ja, dann fangen wir mal an.
Also ich zeig mal, was wir am Start haben.
Wisst ihr, was ich noch unbedingt bräuchte?
So ein...
So ein Wireless, so ein Wireless-Ding zum Labern.
Also,
ich zeig euch, was wir am Start haben zum Testen.
Also wir haben einmal, oh fuck, wo hab ich den jetzt hin?
Nein. Wo hab ich den...
Wo hab ich den Gigabit Ethernet
Adapter hin? Den hatt ich doch eben in der Hand.
Wo is er?
Leute,
Chat, wer hat den weg?
Wer, wer hat ihn?
Ich hab den euch doch eben gezeigt, liegt der jetzt dahinter
oder was?
Wo zum Teufel hab ich den hingelegt?
Beim Tablet holen mitgenommen, vielleicht?
Keine Ahnung, der ist
immer da.
Boomer-Gehirn, Alter.
Ähm. Tja, wo ist denn der, wo hab ich den denn hin?
Kann doch nicht so weit hin sein.
Vielleicht hab ich den echt...
Ich, ich glaub...
Ich guck mal kurz rum, ich glaub, ich hab den
beim Tablet holen mitgenommen.
Okay, da ist er nicht. Okay, wir müssen, wir müssen
jetzt erstmal den Adapter finden.
Der kann ja nicht weit sein. Ich mein, hier sind die
Switche, hier ist das
alles klar, hier ist der Raspberry Pi,
der Adapter, den hab ich eben in die Kamera gehalten.
Das heißt, ich kann den im Prinzip,
wenn ich mich rumgedreht hab, der liegt auf
meinem Stuhl, Leute.
Bester, der Adapter-Champ,
da liegt er. Übrigens, wer sich fragt,
was das ist, ähm,
das hier
ist ein 2,5
Gigabit,
achso, ich muss jetzt ja gar nicht mehr auf den Monitor gucken, ich kann hier unten hingucken.
Das ist ein 2,5 Gigabit,
Netzwerkadapter
über USB.
Und
die Sache ist die,
das Ding ist eigentlich ziemlicher Crap.
Das hab ich mal gekauft auf Amazon für, glaub,
35 Euro, als dem Angebot war.
Und, ähm,
der wird saumäßig heiß.
Und unter Linux funktioniert der nicht wirklich
gut. Aber, aber gut genug, um zu
testen, ob die Dinger auch 2,5
Gigabit können. Weil, die Sache ist nämlich
die, es ist wahrscheinlicher,
dass demnächst 2,5 und
5 Gigabit Sachen
standardmäßig auch Onboard auf Mainboards und sowas
sind, im Vergleich
zu 10G. Ich glaub, 10G
wird's wahrscheinlich im Heimbereich
erstmal nicht geben, wobei es echt easy
ist, 10G. Ähm,
ich zeige euch
mal was. Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich noch eine Netzwerkkarte
hab. Wartet mal. Man kann
einfach auf Ebay gehen.
Man kann einfach auf Ebay gehen
und sich so eine gebrauchte Karte kaufen. Hier fehlt das,
hier fehlt das Loadplash, aber das
ist ja net, ist jetzt ja net so das Ding,
wenn ihr, ne, normalerweise ist Loadplash dran.
Das ist ne, äh, irgendeine
Mellanox-Karte. Hier, da steht's,
was es ist. Äh,
oder auch nicht.
Aber ist ziemlich sicher ne Mellanox-Karte.
Glaub ich zumindest.
Steht nicht drauf, was auch immer. Äh,
kostet bei Ebay, das ist ne
10, also wie gesagt, das ist ne 10G-Karte.
Äh, PCI, was ist das?
PCI, 4-fach PCI Express.
Und,
das kostet 40 Dollar
oder so?
Baut ihr nen eigenen Router?
Ne, ne, ne, wir packen gleich nen Router
und einen Switch aus.
Also,
genau, genau.
Hier ist nix. Das ist, das ist ne,
das ist ne Connext
3, glaub ich. Das ist der mit PCI Express
4. Also der kam, kostet
wirklich nicht viel.
Äh, bringt dir,
bringt das was, wenn man eine 100M
Mitleitung hat, sich sowas zu kaufen?
Es kommt drauf an. Also,
fürs Internet bringt dir das nix, weil 100M
Bit, hast ja gesagt, ist Schluss.
Aber wenn du intern zum Beispiel
ne NAS hast, wo du schnell Sachen übertragen willst,
oder irgendwelche anderen Rechner mit SSD,
die auch 10G haben, dann bringt das was.
Jaja.
Und natürlich bringt es
einen, zumindest rechnerisch,
niedrigeren Ping.
Was aber bei der ganzen Latenz
kaum ne Rolle spielt. Aber man hat natürlich
die paar Bytes für nen Ping
mit 10G schneller übertragen, als mit 1G.
Rechnerisch ist
das nicht wegzudiskutieren, Chat.
Ja. Also, es ist eigentlich
kein Problem. Die meisten Leute
checken's bloß nicht. Also man kann sich
heutzutage echt günstig
nen 10G Setup bauen. Und jetzt
passt mal auf. Also, ihr könnt euch so ne Karte
kaufen, für das, ihr kommt ja fast drauf wie, wie
Shoppingkanal oder so. Ihr könnt euch
so ne 10G Karte kaufen für 30,
30 Dollar auf, auf Ebay.
Und dann kauft ihr euch entweder den Switch, oder
äh, den Router Switch, oder den, äh,
oder den Switch, ich, ich
zeig's gleich. Und, ähm,
dann habt ihr für,
sag mal, ihr braucht 2 Karten
und nen Switch,
dann habt ihr für ungefähr
150 oder 200 Euro nen
10G Setup. Also da
kannst du dich wirklich nicht drüber beschweren.
Shopping24, nee, wenn schon,
wenn schon der, der, der, der,
der Shop Champ.
Shopping Champ.
Kauf Champ. Der Kauf Champ, Leute!
Der Kauf Champ.
Oh, ich darf nicht so fest auftreten. Guck mal,
wenn ich davor, wenn ich davor rumstampfe,
pepo-fett-Schritte am Start,
dann wackelt die Kamera. Was kann
man dagegen machen? Kann man die Kamera
in irgendeinem, irgendeinem Gedingse
hängen, oder so?
Kaufchamp.org
Abnehmen. Ja, der Boden
wackelt. Das ist nicht sonderlich stabil.
Ich könnte pepo-leichtgewicht
sein, und, ähm,
guck mal, selbst wenn ich,
selbst wenn ich den Stuhl wackele, wackelt
das schon. Und wie gesagt, das wackelt
nicht. Das wackelt gar nicht mal so
sehr der Tisch. Der ist ziemlich fest.
Äh, das ist halt hier das, das ganze
Konstrukt, weil der Boden halt wirklich wackelt, wenn ich
hier, das ist nicht sonderlich stabil.
Gimbal-Haltung. Excellent.
Also, dann,
zeige ich euch mal, was wir noch am Start haben. Also, wie gesagt,
wir haben einmal zum Testen das 2,5G.
Das ist relativ wichtig
zu gucken, ob das die Switcher auf
die Reihe kriegen.
Ähm, mit 2,5G,
weil 2,5G ist angesagt
zur Zeit.
Genau, ähm,
dann haben wir diese 10G-Karte,
die brauchen wir jetzt eigentlich nicht.
So, dann haben wir noch ein paar andere Sachen,
die ich auch erst nochmal zeigen muss. Ich leg den,
ich leg den ganzen Krempel mal da hinten hin.
Dann haben wir, wie gehabt,
nen Raspberry Pi 4.
Da gibt's, glaub ich, nicht allzu viel zu zu sagen.
Das ist halt nen Model B, also das, das aktuelle.
Das ist nicht der mit dem USB-Bug,
das ist der, der neue, der ohne USB-Bug.
So, machen wir das mal ab.
Schmeiß ich mal hier weg.
Ich muss, ich muss ein bisschen Platz machen,
dass ich jetzt gleich die Switcher auspacken kann.
Wo leg ich denn das jetzt mal hin?
Hier hinter, so, perfekt.
Rumhängchamp.
So, dann haben wir
zwei, ich glaub das ist ungefähr
nen Meter Glasfaserkabel.
Für 10G auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Zweimal,
zweimal nen Meter. Muss man ein bisschen
aufpassen, die darf man nicht so sehr biegen.
Das mögen die nicht so, wenn man die zu sehr biegt.
Also wir haben hier
zweimal nen Meter Glasfaserkabel.
So.
Und das, das
schmeiß ich mal hier in die Ecke.
Das brauch ich jetzt hier nicht auf dem Tisch.
Leg das mal hier hin und
den Raspberry Pi und das Zeug mach ich ja auch mal vom
Tisch runter
und leg das mal hier auf den Schreibtisch.
Dass ich das jetzt gleich
auspacken kann.
So, ähm, dann
haben wir hier noch was,
achso, ja genau. Dann haben wir hier noch was Nices.
Wir haben zwei Module.
Ich hab jetzt nur die Ubiquiti Module.
Die kommen dann später in den Port rein.
Für 10G. Hier vorne kommen die Glasfaser rein.
Ich zeig das mal, weil ich geh mal davon aus,
dass das noch nicht alle gesehen haben.
Also so, so, so sehen die Module aus.
Also sprich, das ist das Gegenstück
von eurem RJ45
Stecker.
Normalerweise hast du ja RJ45 Stecker
und hier hast du halt SFP Module.
Ich muss übrigens gleich noch ein paar Netzwerkkabel holen.
Fällt mir auf. Ein paar normale Netzwerkkabel
brauchen wir auf jeden Fall auch noch.
Und, äh,
da nimmt man hier das Glasfaserkabel
und macht das dann, ich mach das
immer ver... What the?
Ah, guck mal, da ist noch der Schutz vorne drauf.
Lul weh. So sieht das nämlich in Wirklichkeit vorne aus.
Da, so, hier.
Und, ah, exzellent.
Reingucken.
Ist immer besonders gut zum
checken, ob es funktioniert.
Gerade bei Sachen mit viel Power drauf.
Man muss immer schön reingucken in die Glasfaserkabel,
ob alles funktioniert.
Ne, bloß nicht machen, Leute.
Ohne Spaß, da kann man blind von werden.
Da kann man wirklich blind von werden.
Also, bei den Dingern jetzt nicht.
Bei diesen
10G-Zeug jetzt nicht.
Aber wenn ihr irgendwelche Darkfiberkabel oder sonst was habt
und ihr guckt da rein,
dann könnt ihr wirklich blind von werden.
Das ist nicht ohne.
Das heißt, das Beste, was man dann machen kann, ist vielleicht
also entweder mit dem Finger leuchten lassen
oder auf dem Blatt Papier leuchten lassen
oder am besten gar nirgendwo hinleuchten lassen
und den Check am Port nehmen.
Testest du die Endlaufverschmutzung?
Ne, ich habe gar nichts dafür, um das zu testen.
Genau.
So, und so funktioniert das ganz.
By the way, das macht man übrigens so, ne?
Ich habe das falsch gezeigt.
Warte mal, wie macht man das nochmal richtig?
So?
Genau, das kann man irgendwie...
Dass es nicht so leicht rausgeht.
Fragt mich nicht.
Ich check's gar nicht, genau.
Hat das dann irgendwie so...
Hat man das... Hm.
Ja, Chat, wer ist jetzt der Netzwerkprofi?
Wie macht man das richtig?
Was macht man mit diesen komischen Dingern hier, außer dran ziehen?
Und Chat gucken.
Wer ist Big Brain?
Der ist zum...
Der ist zum rausziehen, ja das weiß ich.
Ist der nur zum...
Ist der nur zum rausziehen?
Ernsthaft?
Ich habe gedacht, damit könnte man vielleicht
das Kabel noch sicher vor dem rausgehen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, wenn man das Modul rausziehen will,
braucht man auf jeden Fall den Knopf,
also den Hebel hier hinten dran.
So, und so funktioniert das Ganze dann.
Glasfaserkabel, zweimal Module, auf geht's.
So.
Probieren wir dann aus.
Und hier haben wir noch was.
Massive.
Aber kein Paintschamp.
Und zwar,
das ist die günstigste Variante, Switche
mit SFB Plus Ports miteinander zu verbinden.
Das ist ein Direct Attach Kabel.
Das ist im Prinzip ein Kupferkabel.
Ich mach mal kurz hier...
Ihr seht, das ist relativ neu, das habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Hier sind noch diese Dinger dran.
Ja, da.
Ich mach das gerade mal ab.
Das ist immer...
Findet ihr das auch nicht so...
Ich finde das ultra nervig, ey, diese...
Dieses gefuddeln mit diesen Dingern immer.
Wisst ihr was?
Wo ist der...
Wo ist der Seinschneider Champ hin?
Hier.
Hier ist die Arbeit, wenn man jetzt einfach hier...
Blub.
Getschreckt.
Warum sollte man das aufdingsen, ne?
Zack. Sehr schön.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich kann gerade nicht gucken, ich habe das Kabel in der Hand.
Ähm...
Sexyrexy185, danke schön für den Sub.
So.
Und das ist ein Direct Attach Kabel.
7 Meter. Das ist das längste, was geht.
Habe ich absichtlich genommen.
Weil ich wollte mal ausprobieren, ob das funzt.
7 Meter ist fragwürdig schon, ja.
So, ähm...
Lege ich auch mal auf den Schreibtisch.
Und jetzt, Leute, ich wetze nochmal schnell raus
und hole noch eine Packung Netzwerkkabel.
Brauchen wir nämlich zum ausprobieren.
Auf geht's.
Jetzt guckt mal, was ich hier habe.
Nur für euch.
Extra, extra für euch
habe ich das aufgehoben.
RGB Netzwerkkabel.
Ja, so ist es.
Ihr seht, die sind auch noch neu.
Warum das Kabel fragwürdig ist?
Weil ich mal irgendwo gelesen habe,
dass du ab 5 Meter für Direct Attach Kabel
irgendwelche Active Verstärker
oder sowas brauchst.
Ja.
RGB Netzwerkkabel.
Und zwar das sind, wie lang ist denn das?
Das ist kein Meter.
Das sind 25 cm oder sowas.
Mini Netzwerkkabel.
Die werden wir wahrscheinlich auch gleich noch brauchen, denke ich mal.
So, aber ich würde sagen, jetzt gucken wir uns mal den Switch an.
Switch Champ.
Ich muss das jetzt alles mal auf einen Platz auf meinem Schreibtisch legen,
weil sonst
finde ich das garantiert nicht mehr gleich.
So.
Raspberry Pi Netzteil.
Muss auch weg.
Ach ja, und dann habe ich hinten noch
im Serverraum, hier auf der anderen Seite,
habe ich noch ein Modul.
Und zwar ein,
das kann ich aber erst später holen.
Und zwar ein, wo habe ich es?
Sekunde.
Und zwar so eins.
Allerdings
SFP Plus auf RJ45.
Das probieren wir auch aus, wie das mit den Switchen
funktioniert.
Okay.
Arm revealed.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit schon Dinge revealed.
Okay, Leute, Chat, jetzt könnt ihr euch mal aussuchen.
Mit was
wir machen mal eine Abstimmung.
Mit was wollen wir anfangen?
Wollen wir mit dem Router Switch anfangen?
Das ist der da oder mit dem Switch?
Also.
Ich mache mal eine Abstimmung.
Mal gucken, wie das geht.
Slash Poll.
Also.
Mit was
anfangen?
4x10G Router Switch.
2x10G
8x1G
Reiner
Switch.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Jetzt müsste die Abstimmung,
eigentlich müsste der Abstimmungs-Champ
jetzt aktiv sein.
Jetzt müsste der Abstimmungs-Champ
Was ist bei 50-50?
Dann beten wir den großen
PogChamp an und gucken, was rauskommt.
Dann fragen wir
Pierre Agilet.
Wie lange habe ich denn die Umfrage eingestellt?
Wie lange geht denn das?
Zwei Minuten. Na gut, dann warten wir halt zwei Minuten.
Zwei Minuten. Na gut, dann warten wir halt zwei Minuten. Warum nicht?
Kann ich mich noch mal kurz hinsetzen?
Bevor ich jetzt die ganze Zeit hier vor dem
vor diesem Presentator-Tisch rumstehen muss?
Okay, also Leute, ich würde sagen,
der 4x10G Router Switch
ist etwas beliebter.
Was macht ein Switch?
Naja, wenn du Snoop frage, ist Snoop Antwort.
Du verbindest Geräte miteinander.
Warum hast du meine Kontakte?
Tja.
Gibt es den Account noch?
Ich dachte, die haben
Herr Aguilé schon
längst gelöscht.
Also, ich würde sagen, der
der Kleine hat gewonnen.
Wir warten jetzt
der Vollständigkeit halber noch.
By the way, ist da Sirius Max
am Start?
Wir hatten doch mal irgendwo ein Tool.
Hattest du nicht mal ein Tool gebastelt, wo
alle Fragen mitgeloggt werden, die an mich gehen?
Gibt es das noch?
Weil ich kann heute nicht den
Ich kann heute nicht den
ganze Zeit den Chat gucken.
Das heißt, ich werde definitiv Zeug übersehen.
Was ist mit dem Salami Emote
passiert? Meinst du das hier?
Gibt es das nicht mehr?
Es gibt kein Salami mehr?
Warum das denn?
Das ist weg. Das Emote ist weg.
Die haben das gelöscht.
Warum das denn?
Warum?
Alter.
Verstört so ein Emote jetzt irgendwelche Leute
oder was?
Man kann auch wirklich dafür sorgen,
dass keiner mehr Spaß an irgendwas hat.
Jaja, ich weiß.
Das Emote ist entfernt.
Suckt, Alter.
Aber Better Twitch TV hat das bestimmt noch.
Salami.
Ne, auch entfernt.
FFZ.
FFZ hat das Salami nicht mehr.
Kann das nicht euer Ernst sein, oder?
Salami Emote ist weg.
Wir müssen unbedingt ein neues Salami Emote suchen.
Ich fand das ehrlich gesagt lustig.
Ich meine, gibt es wirklich Leute,
die an so einem Emote getriggert sind?
Das ist doch lustig.
Ich meine, das ist ein Frosch mit einer Salami.
Natürlich ist uns allen klar,
was damit gemeint ist.
Aber das ist ja gerade ein Gag da dran.
Ich finde es nicht schlimm.
Obscene or inappropriate Emotes.
Obscene ist das.
Obscene.
Alles klar.
Warum sind die Leute immer wegen allem
so getriggert, Alter?
Muss das echt sein?
Obscene or inappropriate Emotes.
Hoffentlich legt es einen auf FFZ hoch,
dann kann ich es wieder reinmachen.
Okay.
Also, auf geht's.
Abstimmung zuerst.
Den Switch.
Den Router Switch, den kleinen.
Chat hat abgestimmt.
Was willst du mit dem Router testen?
Das Gerät an sich.
Router.
Also, fangen wir mal an.
So, Leute.
Haben wir noch irgendeinen
Chat...
Ich muss mal schnell gucken.
Chat.
Ich hab doch auch mal sowas gebastelt.
Ich hab doch auch mal sowas...
Wartet mal.
Ich hab doch mal sowas gebastelt.
Was Chat-Messages mitlocken kann.
Was an mich geht.
Das starten wir jetzt einfach mal.
Das war das...
Wie hieß das Ding?
Pepega Board, oder?
Das hatte so ein richtig...
Net3 hieß das.
Das hatte so einen richtig dummen Namen.
War es das?
Wow, fuck, Alter.
Already in use.
Ah, ne, das ist es hier doch schon.
Oh, ich glaub, das ist das Pepega Board, Leute.
Schreibt mal was
mal gucken, ob es aufploppt.
Tanguy11, dankeschön für den Sub.
Nice!
Mein Zeug
funzt noch. Excellent, excellent.
So.
Das lockt jetzt alles mit.
Bam. Achso, den Knopf hab ich nie implementiert.
Der geht ja gar nicht.
Lul, weh.
Erstmal alles wieder gelöscht.
Gibt's da jetzt Alternative?
Ach, ich weiß nicht.
Muss ich alles löschen.
So, okay. Jetzt hab ich hier den Chat-Lock.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Der ist
aus dem YouTube-Game weg.
Okay, nice.
Also, falls ihr irgendwelche...
Dann geh ich jetzt noch mal ganz schnell den Chat durch,
bevor ich jetzt irgendwas übersehen hab.
Mal auf die Schnelle.
Adwoblors.
Ich glaub, so viel gab's da noch nicht.
Warum neue Switche?
Weil ich die Geräte geil find.
Brauchen tu ich sie nicht wirklich.
Hab nix, oder?
Das hatten wir schon.
Das Auspackvideo parallel aufnehmen.
Xhack,
dankeschön für den Sub. So, sehr schön.
Auf geht's. Massive.
Massive-Brain-Umfrage.
Recursion-Umfrage.
Das machen wir vielleicht später.
Aber,
jetzt. Okay, ich warte noch
eine halbe Stunde.
Also, auf geht's.
Wir fangen mit dem Kleinen an.
Das hier ist der
8-Port-2-2
2-10-G-8-Port-1-G-Switch.
Den machen wir jetzt erstmal weg.
So, da ist er.
Erstmal den Stuhl hier hinter mir
wegmachen, der ist ein bisschen im Wege.
Also, Cloud Switch
Series.
Gucken wir mal rein. Ich hab vor kurzem
gehört, dass da kein Name irgendwie
Anschrift oder sowas drauf ist. Aber, ne, ist nicht.
Alles klar, man weiß ja nie.
Auf geht's.
Gucken wir mal rein. Das Ding ist relativ klein.
Massive-Handbuch dabei.
Alles klar, also,
wer es nicht sofort lesen kann, ist eindeutig
äh, huge, huge Boomer.
Ich hoffe,
ihr könnt das alle noch gut lesen.
Also, wahnsinnig massive große
Schrift. Vor allem das hier unten ist riesig groß.
Braucht
eh keiner.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Leon Buckney, das klappt nicht.
So, ähm.
Maus da wegmachen.
Der Scam Train, Akku, Dankeschön für 2 Monate.
So, das kommt weg. Das hier ist das Gerät.
Und ich, ich versuch jetzt euch
mal die Features davon zu zeigen, soweit
ich die noch aus dem Kopf weiß.
Ihr könnt auch gleich nochmal auf die Webseite
gucken. So, das ist alles was dabei ist.
Der Switch, beziehungsweise der, der
Router-Switch. Aber es ist eindeutig mehr
ein Switch als ein Router. Der hat zwar
Router OS, gucken wir uns gleich an.
Und, ähm.
Aber, der ist jetzt nicht dafür gedacht
irgendwie, bei 10G
äh, sich Firewall regeln
und Gerute und sonst was zu machen. Er kann's, aber
ist nicht dafür gedacht. So, und
es ist ein Netzteil dabei. Das war's.
Fertig. Mehr gibt's nicht.
Leer ist. Guckt, hier da.
Nix drin.
Erstmal in die Ecke pfeffern
das Teil. Bam.
Das ist da auch weg.
Ähm.
Hab Salami geupdatet. Nice.
Aber, du kannst das nicht hochladen.
Bei Bella Twitch TV, die blocken das doch bestimmt.
Wie konntest du da was hochladen?
Okay.
Add to Channel.
Wupp S Salami.
Excellent.
So, ich hab's geadded. Wenn ihr den Chat refresht,
habt ihr wieder Salami. Je nachdem, wie schnellst
ihr das checkt. Wobei, ne, Moment.
Wupp S geht nicht doppelt. Wupp S
ist schon belegt. Wupp S ist für
Smoke. Das geht nicht. Du musst das,
du musst das, ähm,
du musst das umbenennen.
Wupp S ist schon belegt.
Nenn's Wupp...
Wupp Wurst. Wurst.
Nenn's Wupp Wurst. Das ist gut.
Wupp Wurst.
Wie hast du das geschafft, da hochzuladen, ohne dass sie das
genehmigen müssen? Hast du irgendwie nen Premium
Account oder so?
Warum ist die Musik auf einmal so laut?
Okay, wunderbar. Geht's noch? Jawoll.
Also.
Rotfilter, okay.
Das Brillenlogo, das ist irgendwas
von diesem, von, von dem
Kameraübertragungsding.
Muss das neu adden?
Wupp Wurst. Added to Channel.
Wupp Wurst ist drinne. Auf geht's.
Ähm, wir sollten das bei
FFZ hochladen. FFZ hat mit dem Emote
wahrscheinlich keine Probleme. Ihr müsst aber Chat
refreshen. Also, angezeigt wird,
wird's noch nicht.
Okay, auf geht's.
Also.
Wir haben dabei den Switch, den packen wir jetzt mal aus.
Und ich versuche euch jetzt mal die Features zu zeigen,
die das Ding hat. Man sieht schon,
sonderlich viel dran ist nicht an dem Teil.
Ähm,
man bekommt hier ein ziemlich dünnes Teil.
Switch mit 4 Ports.
SFP Plus.
Die haben vorne immer solche,
solche Schutzkappen drinne. Man muss sagen,
so blöd's klingt,
man erkennt,
man erkennt die, ähm,
den Preis von dem Switch schon ein bisschen
an den SFP Plus Schutzklappen.
Weil, äh, der 500 Euro
teure Ubiquiti Switch, der hat zum Beispiel
schöne Gummi-Schutzklappen.
Und der Mikrotik hat bloß so
ganz billige AliExpress-Schutzklappen.
Nicht, dass es in irgendeiner Art und Weise
relevant wäre, aber so ist es halt.
So, also.
Zehn, viermal 10G-Ports.
Und einmal, den man
auch per PoE benutzt.
Einmal einen
1-Gigabit-Port.
Der ist, wie gesagt,
der funktioniert ganz normal,
als normaler 1G-Port.
Ist aber hauptsächlich auch für PoE gedacht.
Also sprich, wenn man nicht das mitgelieferte Netzteil
benutzen will und
man hat einen PoE-Switch,
kann man das hier drüber versorgen.
Ich hab keinen PoE-Switch, mit dem man
das ausprobieren könnte jetzt.
Sobald PoE mit Mikrotik
eh so ein bisschen komisch ist,
vor allem, wenn du nicht
Mikrotik-Sachen damit verwenden willst.
Zum Beispiel kannst du damit halt nicht
48V und 24V
gleichzeitig machen und so.
Aber wie gesagt, PoE habe ich eh
bis auf die Access-Points nicht im Einsatz
bei mir. So, so sieht das Ding aus. Man sieht,
mal zum Vergleich, ich lege euch mal den Raspberry Pi
daneben, dass ihr so ungefähr die Größe einschätzen
könnt. Das Ding ist ziemlich klein.
Äh, der Mauszeiger, wartet mal.
Heck, wait.
So, also das Ding ist
ziemlich klein. Guckt mal hier, Raspberry Pi
daneben.
Guckt euch das mal an. Also,
der Switch ist nicht groß.
Der ist so
1, 2,
1,5,
na nochmal 1, so 3,
die Fläche von 3 Raspberry Pis
ungefähr. Also man sieht, das ist nicht
sonderlich groß. Ähm,
wird wahrscheinlich ein bisschen wärmer, weil
das ist auch ein Feature, hab ich, also was heißt
ein Feature? Eher ein Geldspar-Feature bei dem.
Das Ding ist passiv gekühlt, also da ist keine,
da ist nix drinnen. Und
auch ein cooles Feature, was es in dieser
Preisklasse selten gibt, zwei
Netzteile.
Seht ihr das? Man kann zwei
Netzteile reinmachen. Was schon
ziemlich nice ist.
Ähm,
wofür das hier ist, hab ich ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Zur Erdung oder so.
Da war ich es nicht.
So, und im Endeffekt
war's das. Viel zu sehen gibt's
da jetzt nicht. Wir machen jetzt mal
in der SFP-Plus-Port die, den Einser.
Machen wir mal
raus, legen das da rein
und nehmen mal so nen
Modul. Und so,
das ist quasi euer RJ45-Stecker hier.
Gucken, dass ich das richtig rum
reinmach.
Ja, ich hab's richtig rum drin.
Guckt hier, zack.
Einführen.
Und zack, so.
So sieht's dann aus, wenn's drin ist.
Und da kann man jetzt zum Beispiel
so ein Glasfaserkabel nehmen.
Kann das Glasfaserkabel nehmen
und kann das dann, wenn man die
Kappe abgemacht hat,
einstecken. So, und so
und so sieht das Ganze dann aus.
Also,
das ist quasi was anderes, als man so kennt
mit RJ45-Kabel. So sieht das mit
Modul und Glasfaserkabel aus. Aber,
man kann das natürlich auch, wie gesagt,
mit nem Direct-Attach-Kabel machen.
Das ist billiger, weil,
das muss man vielleicht an der Stelle auch nochmal sagen,
für längere
Übertragungsstrecken. Also, wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel
von eurem Serverraum
keine Ahnung,
in den Keller wollt oder ins Erdgeschoss
oder sonst wo, je nachdem, wo das ist.
Oh, was ist hier los? Subscriptions?
The fuck?
13, danke schön für die Sub. Wie viele gibt's denn schon?
Fünf Stück? Massive. IQ
des Chats wird da hier komplett am
explodieren.
Wer hat denn was gekriegt?
Katotz?
Sanderwolf?
Kampfkevin?
PathosDev?
HogOps?
HogOpsGaming?
Dankeschön für die gegifteten Subs, Leute.
Falls ich irgendwas übersehe, seht's mir nach, Leute.
Ich muss auf zwei Sachen gucken.
Ähm, gut.
Nee, nee, nee, mit Fabian
spiel ich das eher nicht.
So, und
also sprich, wenn man längere Strecken
überbrücken will, sag mal so, alles ab 10 Meter
vielleicht, und dann vorbei.
Das muss man halt gucken. Dann braucht man die Kombination
aus SF4 Plus
Modul und Glasfaserkabel.
Man kann allerdings, wie gesagt, was
deutlich billiger ist,
man kann ein Direct-Attach-Kabel nehmen.
Moment.
Man kann ein Direct-Attach-Kabel nehmen.
Wow, wow, wow. Jetzt fällt die Hälfte gleich wieder runter.
Und das vorne rein machen.
Das ist ein 7 Meter Direct-Attach-Kabel.
Das kostet
35 Euro. So.
Und 35 Euro kostet normalerweise allein
ein Modul, wenn's ein günstiges
Modul ist.
Also das geht,
das geht, The Hook, dankeschön, 11 Monate und
M11 Pro, perfekt.
Huge Subs.
Also allein schon das Modul kostet mindestens
35 Euro. 1, ihr braucht ja 2 für
beide Seiten. Eher ein bisschen
mehr sogar. Und
ja.
Also ich hab noch keine
10G. Wo kriegst du denn für
für 13 Euro
ein SF4 Plus Modul?
Also die
Mikrotik-Module gehen so ab
35 los. Die Ubiquiti-Module
gehen irgendwie so ab 40,
45 Euro los. Und die Cisco
und was gibt's noch?
Dell und sonst was gehen dann noch
teurer los.
Wish, Wish-Modul, ja.
Zumindest die bessere Variante
ist auf jeden Fall, wenn's günstig sein soll,
sowas. Ein Direct-Attach-Kabel
35 Euro, 7 Meter lang.
Da gibt's quasi
die ganze Sache schon dabei.
Es ist quasi ein Kupferkabel.
Das hier ist ja unter anderem auch so teuer, weil's Optik ist.
Also sprich, das ist
SFP Plus auf Optik, also sprich auf Glasfaser.
Und das hier ist
tja, Kupfer im Endeffekt.
Da musst du nicht so viel machen,
deswegen ist das auch billiger. Ich glaub ich hab's falsch rum.
Ne.
Und da kann man hier
dran ziehen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall billiger,
das mit einem Direct-Attach-Kabel
zu machen. Und
stimmt, wo kommt der
Cursor her? What the fuck?
Versteh ich auch nicht, ich hab den doch rausgeschoben.
Ja.
Und das hier ist halt ein ganz
normaler, wie man ihn
kennt, ein G-Port.
So. Mehr
gibt's jetzt von außen an dem Ding gar nicht zu zeigen.
Übrigens, die Anzeigen
sind hier vorne dran.
Hier ist nochmal ein Reset-Knopf.
Hier ist Strom, hier ist, fragt mich nicht,
Activity und hier sind die Ports-Geschichten.
Guckt man eh so gut wie nie drauf.
Ich würd sagen,
bevor wir den jetzt anschließen und was machen, packen wir den
anderen auch nochmal aus.
Und das hier mal kurz weg.
Ähm, tja, lass mal überlegen,
was gibt's denn sonst noch so schönes dazu zu sagen?
Ich mach mal kurz hier den Ding wieder
drauf.
Eigentlich nix.
So rein von außen gibt's dazu
nicht wirklich was zu sagen. Ähm,
was ich gesehen hab ist,
es gibt ganz coole 3D-Prints,
wenn man die in Rack einbauen will.
Da hab ich gesehen, hat einer einen 3D-Print
gemacht, so als Unterlage für so eine
Schublade. Da kann man drei
MikroTik-Geräte draufsetzen
von den Größen. Ja, eigentlich ganz cool.
Ansonsten kannst du den nicht Rack-Mounten,
es sei denn, irgendjemand hat
irgendwelche Rack-Mounted-Halterungen
gebastelt dafür.
Würde mich nicht wundern, aber ganz ehrlich,
man braucht das auch, so ein kleines nicht,
eine eigene Höheneinheit verschwenden.
Das kann man auf irgendeinen Untersatz stellen und das mit
zwei, drei anderen Geräten reinschieben.
Bist du Holzverdammter als wegen dem Hemd?
So, ähm, was das da ist, hab ich
ehrlich gesagt keinen blassen Schimmer. Ach, das ist
hier die Stromkabelführung, guck.
Da kann man so machen, kann man...
Stromkabel reinmachen
und dann kann man das hier
quasi, äh...
Irgendwie, das ist eigentlich
eine coole Idee. Ja gut, da muss man
das, da muss man das, da muss man das abschrauben.
Kann man hier...
Kann man bestimmt irgendwie hier das, das Stromkabel
tun. Das Problem ist, ich seh nicht, weil das
Elgato Ring Light mir voll ins Gesicht
scheint.
So kann man dann machen, ja.
Ich glaub, ich mach das jetzt richtig.
Mach ich das richtig, Chat?
So, und dann hängt das, äh, da hängt das irgendwie nicht
drin. Eigentlich eine ganz coole Idee.
So, also, Switch Nummer 1.
Beziehungsweise Router.
Das hier ist tatsächlich
ein vollfeatured Router bei MikroTik,
zumindest was das Betriebssystem angeht.
Also sprich, da läuft RouterOS drauf.
Das spricht, das hat alles, was
MikroTik so zu bieten hat. Von
Firewall-Funktionen, DHCP-Server,
äh, irgendwie,
na gut, WLAN-Config hat das andere auch.
Äh, alles mögliche.
Also alles, was RouterOS kann.
Aber wie gesagt, das Ding ist eigentlich
mehr Switch als Router.
Es kann das zwar, aber vieles halt auch
nur in Software über die CPU und das
kostet halt ordentlich Leistung. Und wenn ich
da paar Clients dran hab, die wirklich mit
10G kommunizieren und da ich da noch
50 Firewall-Regeln drauf hab, dann wird's wahrscheinlich
ziemlich langsam.
Der kostet, glaube aktuell, der ist
relativ günstig. Gucken wir mal.
Ich glaub 120 oder so.
Ja, 120 Euro.
Das ist ein wirklich Hammerpreis,
ja. Das ist ein echt Hammerpreis.
Also 120 Euro,
vier Ports,
10G, ein Port, 1G. Das kannst du dich nicht
beschweren. Und Dual, Dual,
Dual, ähm,
Powersupply und das ganze
passiv gekühlt. Wir werden jetzt mal eine
Sache machen, bevor ich den anderen auspack.
Ich stöpsel
den mal ein und wir gucken mal schnell,
wie viel Strom das Ding verbraucht. Ich hab hier
nämlich so ein, ich hoffe man
sieht das irgendwie.
Erkennt man da was?
Sieht man da was?
0,0 steht da drauf. Sieht man, ne?
So. Das kann
natürlich sein, dass er jetzt erstmal ein bisschen mehr braucht,
weil er sich setuppen muss und
sonst was. Ich will einfach mal einstöpseln und mal
gucken, wie viel er verbraucht.
So, 4,1. Also die Dinger
verbrauchen auch nicht mal viel. Der kann aber auch
nicht viel verbrauchen, weil der ist passiv gekühlt.
Also sprich, der hat keinen Lüfter oder
sowas drin. So, man sieht,
der ist an.
Dö-dö-dö.
Genau.
4,2 Watt. Also das ist ziemlich
low power.
Wir gucken uns das Ganze dann auch mal an,
wenn er ein bisschen was überträgt.
Für was brauchst du denn das Teil? Erstmal haben.
Haben. Beste.
Gut.
Jetzt haben wir den.
Machen wir erstmal wieder aus.
Und jetzt würde ich sagen, packen wir mal
den anderen. Packen wir mal den anderen aus.
Auf den anderen bin ich ja persönlich mehr gespannt, weil
den da hab ich mir
mal geholt vor über einem Jahr.
Den wollte ich eigentlich ein Video drüber machen
und dann verlosen.
Aber das war die Zeit, wo ich nie Videos gemacht hab.
Und deswegen hab ich den immer noch.
Können wir wenigstens mal im Stream zeigen.
Den anderen Switch hab ich mir tatsächlich geholt, dass ich ihn verwenden kann
und bei mir am Schreibtisch.
Jetzt verlosen? Nee, nee, nee, nee.
So, machen wir den erstmal
weg. Und jetzt
kommt der Huge Switch Champ.
Mach den Kram erstmal wieder weg
hier, weil ich brauch Platz.
Huge.
100G auf dem Schreibtisch, ja.
Ich mach 100G an meinen Switch im Serverraum
und dann mach ich
die 1G an die ganzen Geräte hier dran.
Also ich hab quasi einen 10G
Uplink und mein Rechner kommt
an den zweiten 10G Port.
Also genauso, was ich brauch.
Deswegen hab ich mir den geholt.
So, also.
Wie emote banned? Wirklich?
Kann man das nicht bei FFZ hochladen?
FFZ bannt den Kram nicht.
Wird das Teil wahr?
Das werden wir gleich mal ausprobieren.
Okay, also.
Mal kurz gucken, ob da nicht wieder Adresse oder so draufsteht.
Sonst ist es Leak.
Leak as fuck. Nope.
Passt, okay.
Auf geht's.
So, wir haben wieder.
Oh, diesmal haben wir, guck mal, guck mal.
Wir haben ein richtig echtes Manual hier. Seht ihr das?
Massive Manual.
In ultra nicer
Schriftgröße wieder.
Gucken wir mal, ob man da überhaupt irgendwas erkennt.
Ja, okay.
Aber es ist wirklich klein.
Braucht eh kein Mensch.
Erstmal weg damit.
So, was gibt's denn hier dabei?
Schraubsohren. Netzteil.
Ah, ich hab gar nicht geguckt, was das für ein Netzteil ist bei dem anderen.
Moment, das müssen wir mal schnell schauen.
Der andere hat ein.
Ich vermute mal, das ist das gleiche, ehrlich gesagt.
Der hat ein
24V 800mA
Ja.
24V 800mA Netzteil.
Mal gucken, was der andere hat.
Ich geh mal davon aus, das ist das gleiche.
So, packen wir mal
das Netzteil aus und gucken, was das ist.
Das ist ein.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
24V
800mA Netzteil.
Also genau
das gleiche Netzteil.
Was cool ist, da können wir nämlich bei dem anderen
Switch mal Dual Power Supply
Input testen.
So.
Dann packen wir mal aus.
Oh, was ist denn das?
Leute, was sind?
Poggers.
Die hatten ein Rack Mounted Kit dabei.
Seht ihr das?
Das ist ja massive.
Damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet, ganz ehrlich.
Guck mal, die haben ein Rack
Rackgedöns dabei.
Moment.
Wartet mal.
Der Rack Champ ist am Start.
Guckt euch an, der Rack Champ, Alter.
Übrigens, das Weiße sieht bei euch überhaupt nicht aus.
Sieht eher so braun aus.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, das iPhone macht komische Weißabgleich-Geschichten.
Sonderlich hochwertig
fühlt sich das Rack Ding allerdings
nicht an.
Okay, nice. Haben wir das am Start.
Hier gibt es noch mehr.
Oh, cool, guck mal, die haben ein komplettes
Rack Mounted Kit dabei.
Das finde ich cool.
Das hätten sie bei dem anderen auch machen können.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen, der hier kostet 85€.
Das ist der Witz.
Ich kann mal kurz die
Lampe kurz umstellen.
Warte mal, wir stellen mal kurz das Licht von der Lampe um.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwie
eine Auswirkung hat.
Ey, ich glaube...
Sieht das jetzt
weißer aus?
Ich glaube, so ist besser, oder?
Also bei mir sieht das jetzt viel blauer aus.
Ist besser, ne?
Oh, jetzt habe ich ausgeschaltet.
Lul, weh, Alter.
So ist gut. Ja, lassen wir es mal so.
Lassen wir es mal so.
Ähm, gut.
Gucken wir uns das Rack Mounted Ding
nochmal an.
Die haben aber ganz schön schnell
das Emote gebannt, ne?
Chainlore, du hast es hochgeladen
und sind gebannt, Alter.
Okay, eine Runde
Rack Mounted. Okay, es
fühlt sich, also,
Leute, das fühlt sich
ein bisschen an wie Gips.
Es ist Metall, aber es fühlt sich ein bisschen an wie Gips.
Sonderlich
high quality, super stabil
ist es nicht. Oh, oh.
Also,
ich sollte da nicht dran rumdrücken.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht sonderlich stabil.
Aber das macht nichts. Es ist auf jeden Fall
ultra nice, dass Mikrotik
für einen 85 Euro Switch, der auch so
schon absolut preis-leistungs-Poggers ist,
das dabei gemacht hat.
Da kann man sich echt nicht
beschweren. Das ist wirklich äußerst
nice. Wie sage ich, die
Helligkeit, kannst du die noch ein bisschen ändern?
Das Lustige ist, so
ist es heller.
So ist es heller, aber die Farben sehen kacke aus.
So sind die Farben besser,
aber es ist dunkler.
Muss ich das jetzt verstehen, in irgendeiner Art und Weise?
Ja, bei euch.
Aber bei mir ist das andere viel heller.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was der mit dem Mauszeiger
für Probleme hat, ehrlich gesagt.
Warum der immer
den Mauszeiger in die Mitte macht.
Bei Cisco kostet nur die Rack Mounts 85 Euro.
Ja, der Scheiß ist teuer bei Cisco.
Deswegen sagen ja manche Leute auch
Shisco. Aber das sagen die, das
sagen die absichtlich, nicht weil es, also
unabsichtlich, die denken,
das spricht man so aus.
Cisco, Cisco gibt es auch noch, Cisco.
Cisco, Shisco,
Cisco habe ich alle schon gehört.
Genauso wie Git, Alter.
Git, Shit, Scheit.
Was auch immer alles.
Spricht jeder irgendwie anders aus.
Okay, so. Erst mal hier
die, die, oh fuck.
Erst mal
die Kiste wegmachen.
Boah.
Alter, stinkt das. Boah.
Wisst ihr,
Alter, was haben die da reingeschmissen?
Alter, Leute, das
riecht,
das riecht wie
kuhscheißen Dünger
auf dem Feld, was da rauskommt.
Kennt ihr das, wenn ihr so frisch,
wenn ihr an so einer frisch gedüngten Wiese
vorbeilauft?
So riecht das, was da rauskommt, Alter.
Ne, das ist kein China-Gram.
Kommt aus Lettland.
Glaub, Lettland ist es.
Okay, ich mach das mal schnell raus.
Und dann mach ich die,
dann mach ich die,
die Tüte zu. Tüte zu.
Tütenchamp. Gehste weg.
So.
Also, da ist er.
Cloudswitch.
Guck mal, bei dem, bei dem,
also, die Bemalung
fühlt sich wirklich nicht gut an.
Die, also,
das, das fühlt sich an,
als hätte es einer lackiert.
Aber,
nicht danach irgendwie noch,
noch mal sauber geschliffen oder so.
Fühlt sich total, ähm,
ja,
rau an, auf jeden Fall. Also,
aber gut, ich mein, who cares?
Das ist ein Switch, der kommt, kommt ins
Surferschrank und dann ist Ruhe.
85 Euro, ja, kannst du nicht beschweren.
So, also, Features.
Dual, Dual Power Supply.
Sieht man bloß nicht. Es hat einen Anschluss.
Aber angeblich
Intel Dual Power Supply. Wir können mal
reingucken, wenn ihr wollt. Wollen wir mal
reingucken?
Wollen wir mal gucken, wie das Ding von innen ausschaut?
Weil wir schon dabei sind, man.
Bevor wir ihn anschließen,
können wir mal, können wir mal reingucken.
Wie guckt man da überhaupt rein? Hier unten das abmachen?
Wie macht
man das auf?
Hier, hier vielleicht? Ne, hier, das ist Erdung.
Hier, hier macht man das
auf, würde ich sagen, da.
Dann, guck mal, gut,
dass ich den passenden Dreher dabei hab.
Exzellent.
Zack, und dafür sind diese Fächer hier auch
richtig nice.
So.
Fächer-Champ.
Gucken wir mal, ob er jetzt aufgeht.
Wow, es knackst.
Ah, ne, daneben sind auch noch welche, guck mal.
Ah, noch offen machen.
Gucken wir einfach mal rein.
Das ist ja wieder typisch, ne? Neues Gerät, das erste, was man
erst, erst mal, erst mal aufschrauben.
Erst mal aufschrauben.
Scheißegal, was funktioniert, erst mal aufschrauben.
Öffnungs-Champ. So.
Jetzt aber. Haha.
Da ist
net viel drin.
Guck mal, hier sieht man auch,
die haben's gespray-painted so irgendwie.
Guck,
das ist, ja,
keine Ahnung. So.
Also, es ist nicht viel drin.
Erst mal übertakten.
Also, was haben wir denn
hier zu bieten?
Das sind die, das sind die Ports.
Das sind die 1G-Ports.
Das sind die SFP-Plus-Ports.
Also, ich zeig das mal so, besser vielleicht.
So sehen die Dinger immer aus von innen.
Diese Röhren, diese Plastikröhren,
die ihr hier seht,
ist für die LEDs.
Die LEDs
sind irgendwo da unten
und über diese Plastikröhren gehen die LEDs dann
hier hin.
Das ist bei den SFP-Plus-Dingern eigentlich normal.
So.
Das sind die, das sind die ganz normalen
1-Gigabit-Ports.
Mit Mac und sonst was.
Warum auch immer.
Ich geh mal davon aus, hier ist die CPU drunter.
Das Ding hat nicht umsonst einen
kleinen,
kleinst-passiv-Kühler.
Und ansonsten hab ich
ehrlich gesagt keinen
plassen Schimmer.
Aber,
es ist im Endeffekt nichts drin.
Also, die scheinen
mir recht kosteneffizient
gebaut
werden zu können, ja.
Gibt's nichts großartiges zu sehen.
Da können wir uns jetzt auch sparen den anderen aufzumachen,
weil da wird auch nicht viel mehr drin sein.
Ist der managed? Ja.
Ja, klar.
Also, du musst ihn selbst managen.
So.
Dann machen wir das mal wieder zu.
Ich bin ja, ich bin ja bei sowas immer
faul.
Und wenn ich jetzt nicht im Stream on wäre,
Scheiße, ich seh das wegen dem
wegen dem Licht gar nicht richtig.
Wenn ich jetzt nicht im Stream on wäre,
würde ich wahrscheinlich nur eine Schraube reinschrauben
und dann, und dann
aufhören.
Aber wir sind ja ordentlich, wir sind im Stream, wir machen das
richtig zu.
Maybe geht es jetzt, wupp Wurst.
Okay, Moment.
Hehe, add to my channel.
Okay, wir haben, wir haben,
wir haben Salami, wir haben
Salami-Ersatz. Refresh mal,
wupp Wurst haben wir jetzt.
FFZ-Emote. Ist jetzt ein Keks mit Wurst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der
schon gesynct hat.
Hat er schon gesynct?
Wupp Wurst?
Geht's, geht's bei euch schon?
Also ich glaub, der hat
FFZ noch nicht gesynct, aber
der ist auf jeden Fall, das Emote ist auf jeden Fall
nice. Also wer es, wer es nicht sehen
kann, der
dem zeige ich
das jetzt mal. So sieht
das Emote jetzt aus.
Okay, ich schraub den, ich schraub den Kram
jetzt mal schnell wieder zu.
Jetzt hätte ich jetzt, jetzt hätte ich mal
einen ordentlichen, man wäre Elektriker-Set, aber
am Start, dann hättste das zackig drinne und hättste
rumgefuddel hier mit diesem kleinen Ding, was
eigentlich da überhaupt nicht dafür gedacht ist.
Ah!
Alter Monkees.
Geh nai!
Mein Problem ist auch, ich seh nur die Hälfte wegen
diesem scheiß Ring Light, alter.
Ich mach das grad nach Gefühl.
So, passt.
Zu ist, nächste Schraube.
So und dann
machen wir das mal an und gucken uns das an.
Wir gucken uns wieder den
anderen zuerst an.
Weil Chat hat ja abgestimmt
und hat gesagt, wir wollen den anderen zuerst
angucken. Dann gucken wir den anderen auch zuerst an.
Aber den machen wir erstmal zu
wieder. So.
Übrigens diese
Sorte Schraubendreher sind ultra nice.
Ich wollt mir noch
das Vera Feinmechaniker Set
kaufen, weil die nochmal ne Nummer nicer sind.
Aber das coole an diesen ist, du hast halt oben
so ein Ding, was dreht.
Das heißt, du kannst das dann so nehmen, die Hand
drauf machen und kannst halt so drehen. Guckt.
Kannst dann quasi so drehen.
Weil du oben die Hand auflegen kannst.
Das ist sehr praktisch für so kleinen Scheiß.
Okay.
Okay, verstehe. Das sind die Schrauben
zum Rack Mounten.
Scheint mir auch ganz sinnvoll.
Okay.
Also, machen wir den mal weg.
Und
nehmen wir mal den anderen.
Und schließen den mal an und probieren mal aus.
Auf geht's.
Zack. Switch Champ.
Ich brauch ein Netzwerkkabel.
Ich überleg grad, wie ich das jetzt mache.
Weil übers Webinterface ist nicht so gut.
Ich würd
sagen, wir
stöpseln den mal ans Netzwerkkabel an.
An das hier.
Nehmen wir mal das.
Dafür ist er ja auch da.
Gigabit.
Gigabit Management Port.
So. Dann
würde ich sagen, stelle ich den mal so irgendwie
hin, sodass der nicht umfällt.
Und wir machen das dran. Und dann
loggen wir uns mal drauf ein.
Achso, was ist denn Default?
Default IP?
Default IP braucht man nicht mit dem Management Tool.
Den findet er über die MAC-Adresse.
So.
An ist.
Wenn er hochgefahren ist,
sollte jetzt irgendwann hier Port
Link Activity kommen.
Ich hoffe, der kann sich synken.
Weil dieses Kabel hängt auf der anderen Seite
an einem
SFP Plus auf AJ45.
Adapter.
Mal gucken.
Die Dinger
brauchen meistens ein bisschen zum booten.
Sie sind nicht so ultra ultra geschwind.
Achso, man sieht glaube ich gar nicht.
Man hat hier gar nichts.
Man sieht hier gar nichts.
Ich sehe auch keinen Link oder sonst was.
Weiß gar nicht, ob der standardmäßig
on ist. Vielleicht müssen wir
echt per SFP Plus. Ah hier, guck mal.
Da. Ist hochgefahren.
Alles klar. Sehr gut. Exzellent.
Anzwischen müssen wir mal auf die
Liste rüber und gucken, ob man erkennt.
Zack.
Der ist top.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich würde mir lieber ein bisschen günstigeren kaufen.
Den auf so eine Schublade packen.
Mit deinem DSL Modem und der Fritzbox
und noch irgendwas zusammen. Anstatt
zu gucken, dass der wirklich unbedingt 19 Zoll
mountbar ist.
So. Schauen wir mal.
Habe ich Winbox drauf?
Winbox. Natürlich nicht.
Die Dinger haben drei verschiedene
Managementmöglichkeiten.
Diese MikroTik Dinger.
Die kann man über Web Interface
managen. Die kann man
über Kommandozeile managen.
Und die kann man über Winbox managen.
Das ist im Prinzip das Web Interface nur besser.
So. Und
ich werde das über Winbox machen, weil
Oh, ich habe noch einen Snapshot. Den muss ich mal
löschen. Der wird immer größer.
Delete. Yes.
Ähm. Ich werde das über
Winbox machen, weil Winbox kann die Switche
über Layer 2 discoveren.
Sprich, du musst einfach nur am gleichen Switch
hängen und der erkennt das.
Wohingegen
das Web Interface
natürlich konfiguriert.
What the fuck?
Muss ich
ein Update machen?
Warte mal kurz. Muss ich ein Update machen?
Das wäre jetzt natürlich äußerst unpraktisch.
Dass man Updates downloaden muss.
Aber es geht ja schnell. Das ist ja das Schöne
an Arch Linux. Die Updates gehen immer wahnsinnig
zackig im Vergleich zu Ubuntu oder
Debian oder noch schlimmer
Red Hat.
Meinst du ein Pi 3 läuft stabil,
wenn man darüber
SAT-IP laufen lässt?
Keine Ahnung.
Stabil werden die Dinger laufen. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Leistung
reicht, je nachdem. Also für Full HD,
wenn du da was machen willst,
mit dem Stream eher nicht.
Aber wenn du einfach nur weiterleiten willst,
stimmt. Warum nicht? Ja.
Okay, wir müssen das mal updaten. Habe ich gesehen.
Alles klar.
Dann updaten wir schnell. Das geht meistens, sag ich.
Downloads da jetzt 895 MB.
Nix.
Ich will jetzt die Emotes nicht doppelt
adden.
Wuppwurscht. Es bleibt jetzt bei FFZ und dann ist es
dann halt das nächste Mal da.
Warum ist der Download gerade so langsam?
Was ist denn das hier?
F?
Ich würde sagen, wir müssen mal neue Lists, neue
Mirrors generieren, weil das halte ich
so nett aus.
Warte mal, wie ging das?
Mirror
Pacman
Oh, wie ging das?
Refresh
Jetzt weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, wie der Kram
funktioniert. Rank
What the fuck?
Nee, das ging ganz anders.
Gucken wir mal, ob es jetzt schneller geht.
Manche Sachen mache ich so selten,
kann ich mir nicht merken. Also
Pacman
Mirror
Package List
Man musste,
man musste, man konnte die ranken.
Wir müssen jetzt mal die Package List
aktualisieren, das wird ja sonst nix.
Punkt 3.1
Oh!
Miss by Speed
Echt, ging das so?
Wir machen das anders...
Pacman
Mirrors
Ah hier, Rank
Moment, wo werden die Dinger gespeichert?
Mirrorless, Pac-Man D, Mirrorless, ah hier, man kann, der versucht gerade aus Frankreich zu laden, ja, Aguilé freut sich bestimmt, ja, bam, guckt euch das mal an, jetzt flutscht es, einfach die Franzosen rausgeschmissen, 40 MB die Sekunde, auf geht's,
so muss das, Pogörs, Frankreich minus minus, ja, habt ihr mitgekriegt, die Bahn hat Probleme, weil so viel Schnee liegt, ich frag mich immer, wie man jedes Jahr vom Wintereinbruch Mitte Februar so überrascht werden kann, plötzlicher Wintereinbruch, mitten im Winter, Mitte Februar, wer hätte damit nur rechnen können, ist genauso wie unser Breitbandausbau, wer hätte damit nur rechnen können, dass es nicht klappt bis 2025, niemand,
die vier Feinde der deutschen Bahn, ja,
Frühling, Sommer, Herbst und Winter, allerdings hat der Witz auch schon so ein Bart, okay, auf, mal Update, let's go, hopp, hopp, ich will jetzt, ich muss den anderen Crap installieren, hat der, hat der die Snapshots gelöscht, ja, was für eine Anbindung, 400 runter, 40 ab, ja, das ist doch bei Unity Media, Vodafone ist aber schon permanent dran und will mir permanent was Neues aufschwätzen,
ja, Kabel, ja, gut,
gibt ja sonst keine Möglichkeiten mehr, mit VDS, VDSL ist ja mehr oder weniger am Ende, mit 250 Mbit, ja, ich weiß, dass es theoretisch noch schneller geht, aber das werden die meisten wahrscheinlich nie zu Gesicht bekommen, ne, ne, das ist Vodafone jetzt, aber ich hab's noch bei Unity Media abgeschlossen,
Starlink, Starlink ist was, also, ich find's nice, wie Elon Musk das hinkriegt, mit Tesla und Raketenstelzen und sonst was, aber es gibt zwei Produkte von ihm, da glaub ich echt nicht dran, und zwar ist das einmal diese U-Bahn-Geschichte und, ähm, Starlink, also, da würde ich mir keine Aktien kaufen, wohingegen ich mir, äh, Tesla-Aktien würde ich mir holen, oder hätte ich mir holen sollen, besser gesagt, ja, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da
es ist und funktioniert und auch immer besser funktionieren wird aber an
starlink und hyperloop oder wie das heißt glaube ich nicht
saling ist auch für die dritte welt gedacht kann man sich jetzt darüber
streiten es gibt ja die vermutung dass es für high frequency trading verwendet
wird weil die verbindung per satellit schneller ist von sagen wir nach new
york nach frankfurt und das ist im prinzip für für stonks leute am
endeffekt hauptsächlich genutzt wird starlink in einzelnen das problem ist du
kannst eine einzelne sache zwar testen das funktioniert ganz gut das sagt aber
nichts darüber aus wie das funktionieren wir werden das mal wirklich viele leute
verwenden du wirst relativ schnell an die
bandbreiten grenze zwischen verschiedenen satelliten kommen wenn du
da mal wirklich viele leute damit verbindet ja das glaube ich nicht dass
das gut funktionieren wird aber ich lasse mich ja gern eines besseren
belehren aber
ich glaube es nicht was hat er was gefällt nix gefällt alles klar es
installieren stonks jawohl ok so und jetzt starten wir winbox und
konfigurieren den switch was ist deine lieblingsmarke bei enterprise switches
ganz ehrlich enterprise switches kenne ich mich nur mit cisco dinge halbwegs
aus das ist auch schon jahre her
da sind wir winbox übrigens das läuft über wine nicht erschrecken
diese switch config software ist eigentlich nur windows only aber
funktioniert mit wine echt gut winbox ist die offizielle konfiguration
software von mikrotik wie gesagt du kannst die dinge über drei verschiedene
varianten konfigurieren webinterface kommandozeile oder winbox winbox
funktioniert einfach am besten auf starten blitz übrigens nices hintergrundbild haben wir da heute
keine schnäpfe am besten für dieooo
die balsamico
das kann ich auch hier
ok
ich nenne mal das war die
unsere
Antwort
sollte nicht eigentlich was discovern
ah hier
Das ist meiner normaler und das ist der connect
Ach ne, was ist das standardpasswort okay
ich habe das eben nicht mal gemacht defaultpassword okay admin no password moment geht das etwa nicht darüber jetzt ernsthaft
jetzt ernsthaft
wo sie mich jetzt dann direkt anstöpseln dass das funktioniert ja gut dass wir
uns in raspberry pi haben ip league lul ich dachte er kann das über layer 2
machen kann er nicht aber das kann man kann er ihnen sehr schön ich kann mir
einfach eine ip geben ich kann ja von der zweite ip an aufs interface aus dem
kopf aller at second ip linux ip es ist ein restart required firefox strip du
musst auf die mac klicken wie und dann und jetzt connect ach what the fuck habe
ich das nicht gemacht
monka ist es bin ich verwirrt ok also was wir jetzt switch mod all interface
ist switch land konfiguration
ich habe keine ahnung was du von mir willst ja ja aber alle ports switcht ist
vollkommen in ordnung so und die sache ist die das ist das ist das komplette
router os was da drauf läuft du kannst mit diesen mikrotik dingern unglaublich
viel machen also das ist das ist massive verwirrung pur was man da machen kann
da muss man sich echt mal eine weile mit auseinandersetzen dass man dass man
dahinter kommt ja also hier kann man zum beispiel die adresse ändern das wäre ich
jetzt mal machen
ursprünglich will jemanden an richtig zutaten und mit einem
klar strategenія die dhcp dann nochmal eine knife indirekt los bleiben was will
man da machen und zwar ich stellte es jetzt mal auf eine lokale ip ein dass ich draufkomme kann mikrotik lineup había que lanzar una vida nueva parte
eigentlich mittlerweile moyer kann die haben glaube ich nun der system firma die das kann ich bin da kommt
ja als nicht kommen per per Pakistantalk beanbank news
Interfaces, WLAN-Gedöns einstellen.
Also RouterOS ist übelst komplex.
Das Problem ist nur, dass es nicht sonderlich intuitiv ist.
Du kannst alles Mögliche machen, aber es ist nicht so ohne.
Also wie man Firewall-Regeln einrichtet, kann ich dir zeigen.
Aber, nee, das ist sonderlich...
Also anwenderfreundlich in Form von Easy, ohne nachzugucken,
das machen ist es nicht.
Also Firewall-Regeln kann ich dir zeigen,
aber WLANs auf dem Router kann ich dir nicht zeigen.
Das ist nur Wissenschaft für sich, da muss ich immer selbst Tutorial nachgucken.
Für WLANs auf dem Router musst du nämlich erst irgendwie
einen neuen Port adden oder irgendwie sowas.
Du musst irgendwie einen WLAN adden mit der jeweiligen WLAN-ID.
Dann musst du dir noch ein extra Interface für anlegen.
Das ist total wirr.
Das ist mit SwitchOS wohl wirklich besser.
Und Firewall-Regeln sind einfach anzulegen.
Du gehst einfach hierhin in die Firewall-Config, sagst add und stellst ein, was du haben willst.
Source-IP, Destination-IP, Protokoll.
Also Firewall-Regeln sind relativ selbsterklärend.
Du kannst zum Beispiel sagen, keine Ahnung, Source-Adresse .0.24,
keine Ahnung, Protokoll, TCP, Destination-Port 5000
und Out-Interface auf SFP plus 3 oder sowas.
Dann kannst du das hinzufügen und dann Firewall ist.
Kannst du zeigen, wie man Subnetze produziert?
Kannst du sagen, wie man Pro-Port definiert?
Äh, was?
Hä?
Du meinst mehrere IPs auf dem gleichen Port?
Kein Schimmer.
Weil du kannst wahrscheinlich in Addresses sagen, du willst mehrere anlegen.
Bricht ja nichts dagegen. Probier mal aus.
Was ist denn frei hier?
86 ist glaube ich frei.
Muss man da?
Oh.
Jetzt hast du zwei IPs auf dem Interface.
Mal gucken, ob was pingen kann.
Oh, geht nicht.
Lul weh.
Hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht, dass es funktioniert.
Tja, kein Schimmer.
Ich bin da auch nicht der Pro, was RouterOS angeht.
RouterOS ist halt nicht so ohne.
Bis man das erstmal gecheckt hat, dauert eine Weile.
Oh, Subnet ist falsch.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Wie muss man das jetzt angeben?
Jetzt hat er es gecheckt.
Guck jetzt die IP auch da.
Das ist die 3WM.
So, und jetzt hast du zwei IPs.
Jetzt hast du zwei IPs auf dem gleichen Interface.
Pro Anschluss ein Subnet.
Ja so, hier.
Such dir einen Port raus.
Such dir einen Port raus und vergab eine IP.
Wobei man hier gucken muss, aktuell ist das Ding ja eingestellt auf reinen Switch-Modus.
Also sprich, alles hängt an dieser Bridge dran.
Das kann man auftrennen.
Allerdings, und das ist halt die Sache,
hast du dann das Problem, dass das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr über den internen Hardware-Switch läuft und langsamer ist.
Deswegen, das Ding ist, obwohl es RouterOS drauf hat und sich Dinger kann,
eigentlich eher einen Switch.
Weil jetzt ist der Port auch egal.
Also sprich, egal welchen Port ich nehme, es sind immer beide IPs verfügbar.
Also es ist egal, ob ich mich jetzt hier an den Port stöpsel oder hier oben an den Port stöpsel.
Die IPs liegen auf der Bridge für alle Ports.
Du müsstest quasi die Bridge erstmal wieder auftrennen in einzelne Ports, wenn man das machen will.
Würde ich aber für den Switch nicht machen.
Bei einem Router ist das kein Ding, da ist es standardmäßig so.
Also bei meinem Router hat jedes Interface eine extra IP.
Aber wie gesagt, das Ding ist halt so eingestellt, weil es auch erstmal hauptsächlich als Switch gedacht ist.
Also wie gesagt, das Ding ist halt so eingestellt, weil es auch erstmal hauptsächlich als Switch gedacht ist.
So, also wie gesagt, das ist RouterOS.
Damit könnt ihr nahezu alles machen, was irgendwie geht.
Ihr könnt die übelsten abgedrehten Sachen machen, ihr könnt NPLS Tunnel machen, ihr könnt IPsec machen, OpenVPN,
sogar eigene BGP-Geschichten ausprobieren lokal.
Man kann da wirklich alles mögliche mitmachen.
Im Zweifelsfall kann man da drüber auch Commandozeilen-Config machen.
Aber es ist nicht auf einer halben Arschbacke gemacht.
Also es ist nicht so einfach.
Ja?
Also wie gesagt, so Sachen wie Firewall-Regeln und Adressenanlegen sind noch halbwegs selbst erklärend.
Der DHCP-Server ist auch noch halbwegs selbst erklärend, wenn ihr wollt, dass das Ding IPs vergibt.
Die WLAN-Config ist schon wieder eine ganze Ecke komplizierter.
Und man kann echt verdammt, verdammt viel mitmachen.
So, also das ist RouterOS, exzellent.
Jetzt können wir uns mal gucken, ob wir uns auf dem Webinterface einloggen können.
Ja, da sind wir.
Und wenn man sich über das Webinterface das erste Mal einloggt, kriegt man auch so einen Mini-Quick-Guck.
Hier, U-Mode, hier kannst du übrigens auch umschalten zwischen Router-Mode und Switch-Mode.
Aber man will das Ding eigentlich nicht defaultmäßig im Router-Modus betreiben.
Das ist hauptsächlich ein Switch.
Das ist wie gesagt auch, das hat gar nicht die CPU, um irgendwie 10G da in Echtzeit durchzuhuten mit Firewall-Regeln dazwischen und sowas.
Kannst du vergessen.
So.
So, also.
Ist das dann Bridge oder Switch?
Das ist das Gleiche.
Ein Switch ist quasi eine Bridge mit mehreren Ports.
Das ist genau das Gleiche.
So, dann würde ich nämlich jetzt sagen, jetzt kommen wir mal zu der anderen Sache.
Und zwar, ich will mal gucken, ob das funktioniert mit den Ports.
Ob das meine Module frisst.
Da muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Mir fällt gerade auf, ich kann das gar nicht ausprobieren, weil ich kein SFP Plus, keine Kiste mit SFP Plus habe.
Aber wir können den Raspberry Pi ausprobieren mit der 2,5G.
Mit dem 2,5G-Ding.
Also, das probieren wir jetzt nämlich mal aus.
Und zwar, wir haben hier die 10G-Ports.
So.
Ich werde das jetzt übrigens mal abziehen, dann verliere ich jetzt die Verbindung, weil ich brauche das gleich.
Ich muss jetzt nämlich gleich hinten zu meinem Serverschrank und das Modul rausziehen, wo das dran ist.
Und ich schließe mal, dass wir das Ding weiter managen können.
Ich schließe mal hier ein anderes Kabel dran an, von meinem Desktop-Switch.
Hoffentlich reicht das Kabel.
Wartet mal Leute, ich hoffe, das Kabel reicht.
Wer kam?
Ich.
Ja, ich kann die MikroTik-Dinger miteinander verbinden, aber damit kann ich nicht so viel ausprobieren.
Alter.
Das ist eine kluge Wurst, Alter.
Okay, wunderbar.
Also, ich habe es am Start.
Und zwar ein SFP Plus auf R45.
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, ob das funzt.
Aber erstmal rein.
Eigentlich kann ich das theoretisch direkt raus machen.
Wir gucken mal, ob es so funktioniert.
Und der Port sollte sich hochfahren.
So, da ist es.
Und jetzt testen wir das mit dem Raspberry Pi mal aus, ob das klappt.
Pi am Start.
Ähm.
Ein paar Netzteile am Start.
Dieser komische Crap-Adapter am Start.
Und dann gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, mit was das synkt, ey.
Es sind nicht immer alle SFP Plus-Module.
Ne.
Wenn du Pech hast.
Wenn du Pech hast, wenn du Pech hast nicht.
Normalerweise sollte das gehen.
Aber wenn du Pech hast, manchmal nicht.
So ein bisschen herstellerabhängig.
So, machen wir das hier dran.
Zack.
Dann brauche ich ein Netzwerkkabel.
RGB-Netzwerkkabel am Start.
Zack.
Machen wir es da dran.
So.
Oh, fuck. Wie kriege ich denn das jetzt?
Ha.
Die Steckdosenleiste ist zu dünn.
Wartet mal.
Beziehungsweise, das ist zu fett.
Das ist zu Pepo-Fett.
Übrigens, wir verbrauchen gerade 6,3 Watt.
Ich muss den Switch mal ausmachen.
Das ist zu...
Kein Platz.
Raspberry Pi dran stöpseln.
Also, ich verbinde mich auf den Pi jetzt per WLAN.
Sei ich gleich dabei.
Ich gehe da per WLAN drauf.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir hier für Platz jetzt noch irgendwie haben.
Das...
Nee, fuck. Passt nicht.
Doch, jetzt passt es. Sehr gut.
Jetzt haben wir den Switch dran.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob er die Kombi erkennt.
Die ist jetzt schon sehr advanced, die Kombi.
Das ist ein SFP Plus auf RJ45-Modul.
An der USB 2,3... 2,5G-Karte.
Wir machen auf jeden Fall auch mal ein Firmware-Update gleich noch.
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel, ob er das jetzt erkennt.
Schauen wir mal.
Äh, Pi-Ad... Ach nee, nicht Pi.
Ubuntu-Ad.
Wer sollte die 150 als IP haben?
Wenn ich nicht ganz falsch liege.
Jubantu.
Da sind wir.
Hups.
Prediction wird es funktionieren, ich denke schon.
Also, ifconfig...
Also der Raspberry Pi erkennt gerade schon mal gar nicht die Netzwerkkarte.
Was ziemlich suckt.
Was ziemlich...
Was ziemlich ein Müll ist.
Monkeys.
Wie das USB-Kabel ist bad.
Jetzt mich verarschen? Das ging doch eben noch.
Wartet mal.
What the fuck?
Er blinkt auch.
Ah, jetzt geht's. Okay. Easy.
Okay.
2500 Mbit, alles klar.
Ja, da ist er doch.
Excellent.
So, also...
Bester Name für eine Netzwerkkarte auf jeden Fall.
Also, ich meine, er erkennt es schon mal.
So, ifconfig...
Geben wir dem Ding mal eine IP.
22168.
Was war da standardmäßig drauf?
88, ne?
So.
Ping.
88.1, jawoll.
Funst.
Nice.
Also erreichen kann er den Switch schon mal.
Ähm, der Switch ist halt sonst nirgendswo angestöpselt.
Deswegen muss ich mir da jetzt mal einen...
einen Firefox installieren, dass wir per X-Forwarding draufkommen.
Big Brain Tactics.
So.
Das heißt, das Funst, das macht mich doch schon mal echt...
zuversichtlich.
Also, wenn...
wenn das auch synkt mit 2,5G...
Wir können mal gucken, was er übertragen kann.
Ne, können wir nicht, weil ich keine Gegenstelle dran hab.
Mit der wir das ausprobieren können.
Hm.
Ich könnte jetzt...
Ich könnte doch...
Wisst ihr, was ich mach? Ja, das ist klar.
Deswegen hab ich das doch gekauft.
Alter, ich bin manchmal echt Monark S.
Guckt mal, ich hab doch dieses Fett.
Deswegen hab ich mir das doch sogar gekauft.
Ich hab doch hier dieses Fette.
Direct Attach Kabel.
Das nehm ich jetzt und steck das an mein...
Ubiquiti Switch im Serverraum.
Das blaue Kabel ist zu kurz.
Das reicht halt hin.
Dann komm ich da nämlich auch wieder drauf.
Dann können wir auch gleich sehen, dass das funst.
Okay, während das installiert, wunderbar.
Dann können wir nämlich auch gleich sehen, ob...
die Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Switchen geht.
Und wir machen dann ein Firmware Update.
So, machen wir hier mal...
den Port noch ab.
Zack, ihr seht, das sind Module komplett am Kabel dran.
Da muss man nix reinmachen.
Einfach anstöpseln und gut ist.
So, mal kurz Headset ab.
Ich stöpsel mal kurz in meinen Switch ein.
Okay.
So, und wenn wir Glück haben, sollte der jetzt den Port erkennen schon gleich.
Lass mal schauen.
Äh.
Der Switch macht grad gar nix.
Eigentlich sollte der jetzt Port ab anzeigen.
An Port ab.
An Port 1.
Das hier ist Port 1.
Lustigerweise, mein Ubiquiti-Switch hinten...
zeigt schon an, dass der Port ab ist.
Aber der zeigt weder...
Guck mal, der zeigt weder Port 4...
noch irgendwie was anderes Port ab.
Hmm.
Verdächtig, verdächtig.
Pi tot? Nee.
Pi funst noch.
MonkaS?
Hallo?
Kann nicht sein.
Ich hab eben schon mal Enter gedrückt.
Und das ist WLAN.
Ich bin bei WLAN auf dem Pi dran.
Der Pi kann überhaupt nicht tot sein.
Wie soll das gehen?
Ah, jetzt funktioniert's ja.
Aber hier oben geht's nicht mehr.
Okay.
Was auch immer.
Ah, das andere hängt noch.
So, schauen wir mal, ob wir...
Ah, guck mal.
Das funktioniert.
Aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Interfaces.
Das funktioniert.
Guck, die ganzen SFP-Plus-Dinger sind oben.
Aber warum wird denn kein Aktivitätslicht angezeigt?
Guck mal, die Ports sind angeblich alle nicht oben.
Obwohl sie oben sind.
Muss man das jetzt verstehen?
Eventuell kaputt?
Nee.
Ich mach mal Firmware-Update.
Schadet nix.
So.
So, ähm...
Okay, das ist jetzt dumm.
Das ist immer noch gelockt, ne?
Ach, ich bin ja auch kein Root.
Lul, weh.
Hab ich vergessen, oder?
Ah, jetzt geht's auch.
Na gut, der hat jetzt keinen Uplink.
Wobei, doch, der hat natürlich WLAN.
WLAN-Uplink.
Firefox.
LED-Snowbar 10G?
Das ist 10G!
Also, die Verbindung ist 10G.
Hier auf dem Internet.
Man erkennt es jetzt nicht so richtig,
wegen der Belichtung.
Wobei, die Belichtung ist,
das iPhone hat einen schlechten Abgleich.
Also, hier.
Da ist kein Licht an,
aber müsste eigentlich an sein.
Oh, da wird sogar ein bisschen warm.
Aber kannste knicken.
Ja, was auch immer.
Ne, ne, die Verbindung geht ja.
Die Verbindung geht ja.
Guck.
Die Verbindung ist okay.
Okay, Firefox ist installed.
Aber ich muss das eigentlich gar nicht machen.
So, also.
Wir machen mal ein Firmware-Upgrade.
Ne, ne, das ist 10G.
Das ist 10G gesynct.
Wo sieht man das nochmal, ob es 10G gesynct ist?
Äh, boah.
Interface-List.
Port-Status.
Wart mal, wo sieht man nochmal,
mit was das
gesynct ist?
Hm.
Das ist immer ein bisschen versteckter Kram.
Okay.
Das muss man irgendwie doppelt anklicken oder so.
Ich kann mich noch genau daran erinnern, wie es aussieht.
Also, wenn ich sehe,
erkenne ich sofort,
wo das
gesynct ist, hier.
Okay, man kann es per Kommandozeile
machen, man kann es garantiert im Webinterface machen.
Ich hab das schon gesehen im Webinterface.
Ich weiß, dass das funktioniert. Ich weiß bloß nicht, wo.
Wenn ich vor mir...
Ich weiß noch genau, wie das Fenster ausgesehen hat.
Aber ich hab keine Ahnung, wo es versteckt ist.
Aber wir können es ja mal...
Äh, achso.
SFP
SFP Plus
Gesynct
SFP Connector
Typ Copper. Genau.
RAID 10G und jetzt haben wir 4.
Link 2,5G.
Alles klar.
Der erkennt das auch. Passt.
Komm mal, der erkennt.
Das 1 ist schon mal echt gut zu wissen.
Die Dinger können auch 2,5G.
Was...
sehr praktisch ist, weil 2,5
und 5G ist das, was ich auf dem Desktop
durchsetzen wird.
Also, 2,5G
Link
und das andere hat 10G zu meinem Switch.
Switch zu Switch
Verbindung.
Wunderbar. Wir machen trotzdem mal ein Firmware-Update.
Äh, System...
Das ist auch übelst versteckt. Ich mach das einmal
im Jahr oder so. Äh...
Tools. Nee, das war glaube ich System.
Packages oder irgendwie sowas.
Total versteckt der Kram für Firmware-Update.
Wo war denn der Scheiß nochmal?
Also ihr seht, SwitchOS ist alles andere als
selbsterklärend.
Irgendwo gab es Packages. Ach hier, Packages.
Da ist es doch. Genau.
So. Check for Updates.
Install Version. Check for Updates.
Achso, Moment. Der Switch
hat keine Verbindung ins Internet. Keck wait.
Keck wait. Das geht ja gar nicht.
Was macht Auto-Upgrade? Ja...
Upgraden.
Äh, das muss ich jetzt... Okay, jetzt wird's...
Jetzt wird's komplizier... Jetzt muss ich dem Switch
beibringen. Geh mal ins Internet.
Das heißt, wir gehen jetzt auf DHCP.
DHCP Client.
Oh shit.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob ich das jetzt auf die Reihe krieg.
Okay. DHCP Client
Interface. Äh...
Bridge
ist durchaus okay.
Unter Quick...
Ja, Moment. Unter Quick
kann ich so eine Standard-Setup machen, ne?
Aber wo ist...
Wo ist Quick?
Quick-Setup. Ja, das ist
das Standard-Setup. Das ist das Standard-Setup.
Ne, ne, ne. Genau. Da kannst du hier
nämlich einstellen. Automatic
IP und so. Ne, ne. Wir machen das jetzt mal von Hand.
Also, Interface
Bridge. Warum kann ich übrigens
verschiedene Interfaces einstellen?
Also,
wir wollen die IP. Da stelle ich halt mal ein Interface
ein. Ich hab's angeschlossen.
Also, mein Uplink zum Router ist
an Port, äh, zum Switch.
Ist an Port hier. An dem da.
Das ist Port
1. Port 1.
Ich dachte eigentlich, ich muss die Bridge
angeben. Aber okay.
Port 1.
Advanced. DHCP-Options.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Status stoppt.
Enable.
Ja, genau.
Deswegen. Ich muss Bridge angeben.
Hätte mich auch sehr gewundert, wenn nicht.
Searching.
Bam. Hat eine IP gekriegt.
Easy. 2, 1, 3, 6.
Na, das ist
jetzt ja einfach, hä?
Addresses. Und jetzt sieht man es hier. Guck.
Wir haben 6 Nachts
von Hand vergeben. Die Dynamic.
Deswegen ist ein D vorne dran.
Ähm.
Haben wir jetzt Dynamic IP gekriegt. Das ist doch
gar nicht so einfach. Okay, also. Tools.
Tools.
Packages.
Alter, ist der Kram unüberse...
Ne, nicht Tools. System. Packages.
Check for updates.
Also.
IP-Leak. Mon-KS. Oh nein.
I'm in.
Also, wir können updaten.
Guck mal. Vom 3. Februar.
Dann updaten wir ihn mal.
Download and install. Und wir gucken mal
dann, ob die Links
jetzt, ob die Links wieder on kommen.
Weil aus irgendwelchen Gründen
ist er ja der Meinung.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist er ja der Meinung,
wir haben kein
BILD. Also keinen
Link. Uplink- Anda stake.
Linkdown. Lustigerweise hat Linkup
Linkdown beim 1 Gigabit
sofort funktioniert.
Wir machen mal Firmware-Update.
Rebooting. Gucken wir mal zu.
Beim Rebooten.
Noch ist er an.
Ich glaube, zum zweiten Switch
kommen wir heute nicht mehr, Leute. Es ist ja fast schon 21 Uhr.
Ich schließe den jetzt mal an.
Leute, ich schließe jetzt den
zweiten an. Auf geht's.
Ich habe keinen
Platz mehr.
Ich habe keinen Platz mehr für Strom.
Moment. Ich habe da noch
meine special halb kaputte
China-Steckdosenleiste.
Bam.
China-Champ ist am Start.
Die muss ich nur noch
einstöpseln. Dazu muss ich den Raspberry Pi aber mal
ausmachen. Das ist die,
wo ich gedacht habe, dass sie kaputt ist.
Hast du noch einen Direct-Attach-Kabel?
Ja, ich habe noch ein paar.
Aber das Einzige,
was ich jetzt hier zum Greifen habe, ist angeschlossen.
Okay, der Raspberry Pi spackt rum.
Gucken wir mal,
beim Rebooten zu.
Ich mache den Raspberry Pi jetzt erstmal
raus.
Ab. Zack. Einfach ausschalten. Easy.
Wow. Ey, das Elgato-Netzteil
wird ganz schön warm.
Die China-Steckdosenleiste ist übrigens mega im Arsch.
Jetzt haben wir Glück.
Jetzt geht's. Die hat einen Wackelkontakt.
Wenn das Kabel falsch ist...
Guck mal.
Ah. Voll im Arsch
das Teil. Richtiger Crap.
Okay.
Dann
haben wir den Raspberry Pi hier dran.
Ist es jetzt an? Ja.
Excellent. Und den anderen
Switch, den machen wir da dran.
Ach, guck mal. Der hat den Strom
vorne. Das fällt mir jetzt auch
erst auf.
Der hat hinten gar nichts. Dann können wir den auch hochkant
hier hinstellen. Hups.
Und dann passt's.
Guck mal. Bisschen balancieren
das Ganze.
So. Also der mag
immer noch keine Links anzeigen.
Hat er keinen Bock drauf.
Juckt hier nicht.
Aber wir werden die beiden jetzt verbinden
miteinander. Und nämlich per
richtig echtem
Massive Glasfaser.
Und zwar einmal
Glasfaser mit Modul.
Zweimal Glasfaser mit Modul.
So.
Zack.
Abmachen. Erstmal gleich Vollbestückung
vom Switch hier. Rein damit.
Und...
Ich hoffe, es ist richtig rum.
Na, ist falsch rum.
Und...
Rein damit.
Guck mal. Der Fuss.
Hier gehen die Link-Anzeigen.
Da sind die Link-Anzeigen kaputt.
Was ist mit meinen Link-Anzeigen los?
What the...
Hm. Verstehe ich nicht jetzt.
Aber okay.
Also die Dinger sind verbunden. Scheint zu funktionieren.
Erstmal ein Leck gehabt.
Nee, aber das lag nicht da dran.
Okay. Firmware-Update hat funktioniert.
Check for updates.
Stream... Ernsthaft? Stream war weg?
Hä? Das kann aber damit nichts zu tun haben.
Das kann aber damit nichts zu tun haben, dass der Stream weg war.
Ernsthaft?
Vielleicht hat der irgendwelche krassen Spanning-Tree-Geschichten gemacht.
Mein, mein, äh, Ubiquity-Switch.
Nee, nee, ich hab keinen zweiten DHCP an.
Was auch immer das Sache ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Der hat, der hat wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Spanning-Tree-Geschichten gemacht.
Kein Schimmer.
So, also.
Upgedatet ist es.
Und wir sehen, dass wir immer noch keine Links sehen.
Wunderbar.
Hier der Link funktioniert.
Ihr seht ihn blinken.
Das heißt, jetzt kann ich den anderen Switch auch einrichten.
Neighbors, refresh.
Hm.
Der sollte den doch jetzt eigentlich finden.
Macht er aber nicht.
Ab ist der Port.
Die sollten jetzt eigentlich geswitcht sein.
Also das sollte jetzt eigentlich keinen Unterschied machen.
Ich mein, das ist alles mehr oder weniger ein großer Switch jetzt dadurch.
Mehr oder weniger.
Nö, da findet ihr nicht.
Ach, fuck.
Das kann das ja nicht.
Stimmt.
Du kannst dich damit ja nicht connecten.
Das ist ja SwitchOS.
Okay, wie komm ich denn da jetzt drauf?
Da muss ich wahrscheinlich per Webinterface drauf, hä?
Okay, wo ist der Raspberry Pi?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das, äh.
Du meinst, ich soll den kleinen Strom losmachen, ob die LEDs dann wieder gehen?
Der SFB Plus läuft.
Port ist ja oben.
Und blinkt auch mit Aktivität.
Äh, nee, ich muss den Pi nicht anschließen.
Ich kann, ich muss den Pi nicht anschließen.
Ich geb mir einfach, ich geb mir einfach eine extra IP auf dem Interface.
Aber, hat der jetzt nicht IP-Konflikt?
Ich musste, ich musste das mal runter machen.
Der hat doch jetzt IP-Konflikt.
Mit dem anderen Switch.
Der ist doch, Moment.
Der ist doch jetzt doppelt, die IP ist doch doppelt die Default-IP.
Muss ich erst mal einstellen, dass der den nicht mehr verwendet.
Ähm.
Oh, guck mal.
Es sieht jetzt, es sieht jetzt moderner aus.
Oder?
Die, die Items.
Die sehen jetzt exquisiter aus.
Äh, also Interfaces, IP, Addresses.
So, die muss weg.
Die muss, die muss weg, die IP.
Weil, die, die, die, sonst gibt's IP-Konflikt.
Schlecht.
So, weg.
Okay, wir rebooten, wir rebooten den mal.
System Reboot.
Man kann ja auch in Switch, man kann ja auch in Switch OS.
Ah, cool.
Man kann ja auch direkt in Switch OS, ähm.
Irgendwie switchen, wenn man auf Router OS keinen Bock hat.
So, also Reboot.
Wo ist er?
Reboot.
Yes.
Der Router rebooted hier.
Ach, guck mal da.
Oder auch nicht.
Habt ihr gesehen, aber der Vierer hat Aktivität gehabt.
Ich glaub, der, ich glaub, der checkt's, der checkt's grad einfach nicht mit, mit Link
ab und Link down.
Der ist zu pepega dafür.
Hast du eigentlich schon vor deiner Ausbildung programmiert?
Ja.
Vielleicht geht es jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob du das jetzt schon gemacht hast.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das jetzt schon gemacht hast.
Also, was auch immer, warum die LEDs nicht da sind, ich habe keine Ahnung, aber die Ports
funktionieren.
Wir sehen ja hier oben, wenn der wieder on kommt, ist der Switch gebootet.
Hä?
Er hat was, er hat was gemacht gerade.
Was ist, was ist eigentlich diese User LED?
Ist das irgendwie CPU oder was?
Was ist das?
ok da ist wieder da warum hat er keine leds muss man das irgendwie extra anschalten mikrotik 800
305 ist das ding noch mal genau ca5 led chance of all led was leds auf led ich will leds on haben
system leds ok ok ok dann wir gucken uns mal die led config an system led leds guck mal die
haben hier massive rgb champ what the fuck ist moment man braucht er ernsthaft eine led konflikt
dass der dass der activity leds macht oder was jetzt wirklich
alle leds of never never never off das kann jetzt sein ich wusste noch bei keinem ding
irgendwie led konflikt machen sind jedoch beides kann nicht sein gibt es auch gibt es auch das
gegenstück all led ne gibt nur alle led auf aber das ist anscheinend so guck mal power led und
ethernet led also die die die die die die ein port links ist offen ok ich stelle jetzt mal
was
ein interface status sp plus 1 und zeigt er jetzt was ist dem vollkommen egal achso da ist die led
ernsthaft jetzt wirklich gott led config also wer musste nicht schon beim switch der led konfiguriert
alles klar was kann man da so schönes einstellen alles also bei der led config mal jetzt jetzt
wie aber ich ansonsten die switch route aus
kannst du alles mögliche einstellen ok also jetzt war es war zurück zurück zum Case
also 18 punkt an ip ads ich kann das immer nicht mehr wie hätte ich den zweite second ip interface
linux ipad kann mir das netten naja mit mir geht's kommt wirklich noch hin aber ipad ist der way to go
ja ja ipad hier genau das ist der pdf eigentlich die oder die you have to go ist ja wie diese
ipad ist jetzt das ist das ja also ich kann es jetzt lieber in die zitate gehen also ich habe
leider etwas mehr noch vor mir und dann bereit ich habe jetzt mal in der linke gerät in der linke
und das bin ich noch mehr oder verpasst mal ich habe jetzt mal eine zweite linke zu geben
und das ist meine zweite linke ja hier und die linke ist jetzt der linke das ist der linke
Ja, IP Adr.
Ja, genau das da.
Ne, ne, ne, das ganze, ganze Crap brauchen wir da nicht.
Okay, also.
IP
Add
88.7
Slash 24
Def
NS33
Operation
ist ja gut.
Okay, jetzt haben wir eine IP
auf dem Interface, alles klar.
Mal gucken, ob wir den anderen jetzt pinken können.
6, 8, 8, Nachricht, Punkt 1 und Bäm.
Nein.
Paintschamp, Host Unreached.
But why?
Ist die Frage.
Verbunden ist er.
Verbunden ist er, Aktivitäts-LED hat er auch.
Da würde ich doch sagen,
SwitchOS,
was ist die Default IP Switch?
SwitchOS
8, 8, 1, aber die Frage ist,
auf welchem Interface?
Vielleicht nicht auf jedem Interface?
Doch, bestimmt auf jedem Interface.
Ups.
Tja, äh.
Vielleicht pinkt das auch nicht.
Vielleicht gehen wir einfach mal da drauf.
Hopp.
Okay, ähm.
Dann würde ich sagen, wir stöpseln mal den Raspberry Pi
da direkt an.
Stöpseln den da oben an. Und zwar mit, mit der
normalen Netzwerkkarte, äh.
Nicht mit diesem komischen Adapter
da hier. Gehst du mal fort.
Normale Netzwerkkarte.
Ey, dieser Adapter, ich sag euch, der ist echt gut.
Der macht mich fertig, guckt mal.
Du kriegst dieses Kabel da teilweise nicht raus.
Es ist so beschissen
gemacht.
So.
Seitenschneider-Champ am Start.
Raspberry Pi.
Ups, nicht runterfallen.
Bissi, bissi
voll hier auf dem Tisch, aber okay.
Zack.
Jetzt machen wir mal Port, keine Ahnung.
Port 2 oder so.
Erstmal entknoten das Ganze.
Link, please, up.
Link ist up.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr es seht, aber
der Netzwerk-Link blinkt.
Gut, gehen wir auf den Raspberry Pi drauf und schauen wir mal.
Come on, Raspberry Pi.
Please, lass mich einloggen.
Wo ist das Problem?
Sag bloß, der Pi ist uns
jetzt verreckt. Nee.
Alter, ist das lahm.
Okay, ähm.
Wait a minute.
Ach ja, na klar.
Der Rest, natürlich, der Raspberry Pi.
Aber die Verbindung funktioniert
zum Switch.
Sonst hätte der Raspberry Pi keine DHCP-IP
gekriegt.
Der Raspberry Pi hat eine DHCP-IP gekriegt.
Und es kann nur sein,
weil der Raspberry Pi da dranhängt,
dass zu dem Switch geht
und der hängt per Uplink an meinem Ubiquiti-Switch
dran.
Also im Prinzip geht der Link.
Die Frage ist nur, warum komme ich per Switch
OS da nicht dran?
Hm.
IP add
8.5
slash 24 device
eth0, bam.
Ah, jetzt geht's.
Hä?
Wait, warum geht das?
Das ergibt doch jetzt gar keinen Sinn.
Warum geht das
von dem Raspberry Pi
und warum geht das nicht von meinem Desktop?
Die hängen quasi...
Ich meine,
der eine muss noch zum anderen Switch rüber,
weil die Verbindung funktioniert ja.
What?
Warum?
Ah, äh, nee.
Ich hätte gedacht, vielleicht liegt es an meiner Default-Route,
dass er das automatisch rausschickt,
aber das sollte der eigentlich kapieren.
Wie dem auch sei,
wir können jetzt Firefox aufmachen,
per X-Forwarding.
Achso, ja.
Das ist nicht falsch.
Nee.
Nee, nee, alles richtig, alles richtig.
Aber wie das geht,
weiß ich nicht.
Das muss über die SFP-Plus-Ports gehen.
Letztendlich hat ja der
Raspberry Pi auch eine IP gekriegt.
So, wir machen das jetzt per X-Forwarding.
Ich meine, scheiß drauf, ist zwar nicht schnell, aber
ich meine,
es geht.
Nee, das ist vollkommen egal.
Das ist ja, switchen miteinander verbunden,
denen sind das mit IPs,
ist denen vollkommen egal.
Okay, 1226888.1
Da sind wir.
SwitchOS.
Default-Name Admin, ne?
So, das ist jetzt eher was für die meisten bei euch,
glaube ich.
Mit SwitchOS ist die Sache ein bisschen easier.
Du hast nicht so viele 30 Milliarden Dinger.
Du kannst die Sachen machen, die man so kennt
von einem Switch.
Du kannst Ports benennen.
Du kannst dir die Übersicht von den Ports angucken.
Du kannst Link Aggregation machen.
Was das hier macht, weiß ich nicht.
What the fuck?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das hier tut.
Vielleicht kommst du über SFP-Plus nicht auf die
Das können wir uns jetzt ja gleich angucken.
Link Aggregation.
Man kann Ports klonen wahrscheinlich.
Das ist eine Spanning Tree Geschichte,
vermute ich mal.
Was auch immer.
Stats, Error, VLANs.
Also die Config ist deutlich einfacher
als RouterOS.
Also die GUI ist vielleicht nicht schön,
aber man hat auf jeden Fall
deutlich einfacher die ganzen Sachen
als mit RouterOS.
Brain exploding.
Ja.
So, wo kann ich mir denn jetzt hier meine
Management-IP angucken?
Upgrade.
Das müsste eigentlich funktionieren.
Der Switch.
Okay, Moment.
Wie stellt man hier jetzt ein
Management-IP und sowas?
Das hat SNMP, ja.
Das hat irgendwo auch SNMP da.
System.
Aha.
DHCP only.
Hm.
DHCP with Fallback.
Das ist eigentlich top.
Dann rebooten wir jetzt und dann sollte der
Einschnitt DHCP-IP bekommen.
Weil er kann ja jetzt
den Router erreichen.
Alternativ.
Ja, komm.
Kann man ihm sagen, dass er
neue DHCP ziehen soll?
Okay, rebooten. Wir rebooten einfach mal.
Der rebootet.
Und ich guck nebenbei in meinen DHCP
ob das funktioniert.
Ob da sich was zieht.
Nur über Konsole
führen wir upgraden.
Moment, DHCP übelst
unübersichtlich.
Ja gut, das macht der manchmal.
So, und jetzt haben wir IP.
Hat da sich jetzt was gezogen?
Ja.
Zwei Punkt, nee, das ist der andere.
2.136 ist der andere.
2.137.
2.137 haben wir noch.
2.136 und 2.137.
Oder auch nicht.
Meine Güte.
Die Firma scheint echt
ein bisschen verbuggt zu sein.
Wo ist das Problem jetzt?
Wo ist das Problem?
So, das ist der andere.
Das ist der andere.
Das ist nicht der Switch.
Das ist
der kleine.
So.
Also ich guck grad in meinen DHCP
und da ist nix.
Und da müsste sich ja eigentlich was ziehen.
Macht er aber nicht.
Kann der in die IP?
Nee.
Okay, da müssen wir auf
Fallback warten. 88.1.
Okay, da macht jetzt
gar nix mehr.
Jetzt ist vorbei.
Jetzt juckt ihn gar nix mehr.
Jetzt ist er kaputt.
Nee, kaputt ist er
nicht, aber
kommt man da jetzt dran?
Also weder
weder per IP ist er erreichbar,
noch per DHCP.
Das ist natürlich geil.
Massive Poggers.
Okay, vielleicht hat er einfach nicht richtig
rebooted.
Vielleicht reboote ich den nochmal
von Hand.
Leuchtet? Ja, Activity leuchtet.
Okay.
Mal schauen.
Also
da ist er angeblich.
Der Raspberry Pi ist auch direkt
dran.
Mich echt wundert.
Vielleicht hat er doch ne DHCP gekriegt, aber
ich hab's bei mir im Router jetzt übersehen.
Wenn ich hier gucke.
Mikrotik.
Zwei Punkt.
Nee, das ist der andere.
Moment, ich mach jetzt mal aus und
wieder an und dann gucken wir mal.
Zack.
Die Hardcore-Variante. Kabel raus, Kabel rein.
Ihr seht nix, ne?
So.
Kabel raus, Kabel rein.
So, und jetzt
guck ich mal in meinen DHCP,
ob da irgendwas auftaucht.
iPad. Das iPad taucht auf. Super.
Das hab ich jetzt gebraucht.
Mein...
Mein Raspberry Pi taugt auf.
Wunderbar.
Was'n das?
60? Ach nee,
das ist was anderes.
Ich habe, wenn mein... What the fuck?
Aber wenn mein Pi auftaucht,
bedeutet das, der Switch funktioniert.
Okay, das ist mir zu
big brain.
Das ist mir zu hoch, Leute.
Das muss ich mir, glaub ich, morgen
allein in Ruhe mal angucken. Bisschen rumbasteln.
Nee, also per DHCP
kriegt er schon mal nix.
Per DHCP kommt nix.
Juckt hier nicht.
Wir können n-map Ports scannen.
Excellent.
Nee.
Ich muss hier 25 draufhauen, okay?
Ja, dazu müsste ich jetzt überhaupt mal
in irgendeiner Art und Weise drankommen.
Ich komme ja gar nicht dran, aktuell.
Ich komme ja gar nicht dran.
Noch nicht mal
PX-Forwarding. Gar nicht.
Der Anfang...
Der pingt noch nicht mal.
Moment, meine IP ist weg.
Keck, wait. Da ist er wieder.
Okay, DHCP
zieht sich schon mal gar nicht.
DHCP zieht sich schon mal gar nicht.
Das ist okay.
Also, da sind wir wieder.
Also, Firmware.
Firmware updaten.
Exquisite Firmware updaten.
Mikrotik, CSS 6.1.0
Download.
By the way, Chat, ich hab gesehen, dass ihr was gepostet habt,
aber ich will jetzt mal gucken, ob die das nicht
offiziell auf ihrer Seite stehen haben.
So, Downloads.
Haben wir da irgendwie...
Firmware gibt's gar nicht.
Haben sich gedacht, ne?
Ist so kaputt, verlinken wir gar nicht.
Wir liefern den Karten,
die kaputt aus, haben aber keine Updates.
Exquisite.
Das müssen wir hier, glaub ich, aufmachen.
Ich muss mir jetzt aus dem hier im Forum
ne Beta-Firmware laden, oder was?
Dass das Ding überhaupt richtig funktioniert.
Geil.
Okay, 85 Euro, Alter. Ich hab nichts gesagt, Leute.
LED-Config, ja.
Okay, wo gibt's...
Wo gibt's die Firmware?
RC25.
Okay, erstmal aus dubiosen Quellen
den Kram runterladen.
Perfekt.
Genau das wollte ich schon immer haben.
SwitchOS 2.13
RC25.
Top.
Okay, wie macht man jetzt?
Firmware-Update? Upgrade.
Browse.
Okay, die Firmware ist noch ganz schön kaputt, Leute.
Da sind wir.
RC25, ja, da gab's ein paar verkackte
RCs, wie's aussieht.
Upgrade.
Es gibt noch keine richtige Firmware-Version, anscheinend
neu ist das.
Lol, weh.
Fuck.
Nee, geprickt wird da nix.
Oh, er ist weg.
Rebootet er?
Macht der jetzt irgendwas?
Also, wenn der rebootet, geht natürlich
der Raspberry Pi
auch nicht. Aber der Raspberry Pi
geht noch.
Was mich fraglich stimmt,
ob das Firmware-Update funktioniert.
Also, für 85 Euro ist das ein richtig
geiler Switch, von den Features her.
Die brauchen wahrscheinlich noch 1-2 Monate,
bis die Firmware ordentlich funktioniert.
Es ist quasi der No Man's Sky, der Switche.
Ah, jetzt hat er sich
bei DHCP was gezogen, Leute.
Die Firm- Wow, fuck.
Die Firmware hat's gefixt.
Guck mal. Da sind wir.
Jetzt können wir
da auch drauf.
System.
Ist das verbuggt?
Mit dem Online-Update? Ist das verbuggt?
Irgendwie?
Kann man nicht über das Web-Interface
upgraden?
Aber zumindest die Connection
hat schon mal getan, ja?
Okay, aber zumindest kommt man jetzt schon mal
per Web-Interface auf den Switch drauf.
Link ist ab, 1G,
10G, wunderbar.
Das ist aber von der Config her
schon mal einfach. Jetzt machen wir noch mal was, Leute.
Jetzt machen wir noch mal
eine Sache. Jetzt stöpseln wir mal hier
den Raspberry Pi dran, mit dem
2,5G-Adapter.
Dann probieren wir mal was aus.
Wir haben auch nicht mal allzu viel Zeit.
Passt mal auf, was
wir jetzt machen. Wir nehmen
jetzt den 2,5G-Adapter.
Den da.
Zack. Ups.
Und machen das Modul hier raus.
Machen das Modul hier
in den zweiten SFP-Plus-Port rein.
Falsch rum.
Und nun stöpseln wir die
2,5G mal dran und gucken, mit was der
synkt. Da bin ich mal...
Die Firmware bei dem hier scheint ja recht ausgereift zu sein.
Mal gucken, was er
bei dem macht. Okay.
Port ist ab.
Ja, das backt jetzt.
Jetzt muss ich das erst noch mal rausziehen, glaube.
Dann funktioniert es danach wieder.
Alles High-Quality, wie man sieht.
Aha. Blinkt. Link.
Link ist auch da.
Oh.
Okay, synkt sich. Alles gut.
Alles klar. Gucken, ob der jetzt hochkommt
mit 2,5.
Er ist mit 2,5. Okay.
Das ist schon mal gut, dass das funktioniert.
Leckt das? Hat es wieder geleckt?
Das wäre ein Witz. Das wäre geil.
Okay, der synkt mit 2,5. Oh.
Sag mal, geht der up und down?
Kann das sein? Oh. What the
fuck? Das ist, das ist
jetzt aber die verbuggte, das ist die
verbuggte Netzwerkkarte, ey.
Das ist die verbuggte Netzwerkkarte. Ich habe es
immer noch nicht geschafft, den offiziellen Treiber
zu installieren. Ich habe extra auf den
Pi ein Ubuntu 20.10
gemacht.
Und das ist immer noch verbuggt,
der USB-Netzwerkkartentreiber.
Okay, machen wir mal, machen wir mal
einen Speedtest.
Ich hoffe, der geht jetzt über den
richtigen Adapter.
IP-Perf
und jetzt.
Achso, erstmal installieren.
Ich meine, mit dem Raspberry 3 da jetzt
einen 2,5G-Test
zu machen, ist natürlich Fail.
Aber was willst du machen?
Ich habe gerade nichts anderes am Start.
Und, ähm,
ja. Gucken wir mal, ob der überhaupt über die
richtige Netzwerkkarte geht.
Ne, der geht über Gigabit. Der geht über
Gigabit. Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Der Pi kann er mit 2,5
Ne, ne, nicht wirklich. Nicht, nicht
wirklich. Das ist eher so,
einfach gucken, ob die Verbindung geht
und das war's. Ne, nicht wirklich.
Ähm.
Ich muss, glaube ich, die
Ich muss mich darüber connecten
auf den Pi,
weil der sonst das nicht
checkt, über welchen Anschluss er das
machen soll.
Aber die machen wir mal ab.
Jetzt muss der Pi erstmal checken,
dass er wieder an ist. Oh, ne, hat er schon.
Okay, nice. Wobei, ich kann auch
einfach über WLAN.
Oh, ich blick gerade einmal durch. SSH,
Ubuntu, Add.
Ja, ja.
Äh, SSH,
Key.
Ne.
Was war's nochmal?
Minus R.
Äh.
War nicht SSH, Keygen.
Es war. Wollt man das nochmal entfernen?
Ich mein, ich kann's aus der Textdatei löschen.
Was? SSH, Keygen, minus R?
Wirklich? Tatsächlich?
Ha.
Shit, gedacht, es war was anderes.
So, also. Jetzt sind wir am Start.
Also, listening.
IPerf.
Okay, jetzt geht er.
Jetzt geht er über die, ähm,
über die 2,5G.
2,5G.
Aber das geht, das funktioniert halt nicht, ne.
Also sprich, kannst du knicken.
Der ist zwar gesynkt mit 2,5G, aber
das schafft, der Raspberry Pi schafft
nicht mehr. Und übrigens, Reverse
spackt die...
Oh, geht doch. Guck mal, Leute.
Wir haben einen Ticken mehr.
Einen Ticken mehr als 1G.
Also, man sieht, dass es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Aber der spackt schon mit retrys übelst rum.
Was hältst du von Webmin?
Gar nix.
Also, es ist auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall hat er schon mal mit
2,5G gesynkt.
Und es funktioniert auch.
Das wäre, das würde wahrscheinlich noch deutlich besser
funktionieren, wäre diese
Kack-Netzwerkkarte nicht so verbuggt.
Guckt euch
das mal an.
Jaja, mit dem, ich hab's nicht geschafft, den
Treiber installiert zu bekommen. Ich hab's auch noch mal auf
Ubuntu probiert. Es funzt sich. Vielleicht
ist es ein ARM-Problem.
Ja, nice. Funktioniert auch prinzipiell alles.
Sehr schön.
So, und auf
SwitchOS kann man, wie gesagt,
bei weitem nicht so viel machen, wie mit RouterOS.
Aber es ist halt ein bisschen einfacher.
...
Man kann ihm übrigens auch sagen, mit Wasser...
Okay, das ist ziemlich beknackt.
Warum soll ich den auf 1G stellen?
...
Wenn ich nichts anderes einstellen kann.
Der ist ja total hängengeblieben.
Die LEDs... Nee, die LEDs gehen.
Die LEDs bei dem funktionieren.
Man sieht's
nicht richtig gut.
Aber guckt, die LEDs
bei dem gehen.
Nur die LEDs bei dem
anderen, bei dem da
spacken ein bisschen rum.
Ups.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Errors, Stats.
VLANs. Zeig mal her.
VLANs. Wie macht man
eine VLAN-Config mit SwitchOS?
VLANs. Sort. Das sind alle?
Oder was?
Default VLAN 1. Alles okay.
Only tagged? Untagged?
Okay, only
untagged könnte man
machen, wenn man will, dass da Switched ist.
Also, wenn man da
kein Trunkport oder irgendwas machen will, dann kann man auch
sagen, okay, wir wollen rein.
Darf nur untagged traffic.
Alternativ könnte man auch sagen,
das kriegt ein Default-VLAN und
es nimmt auch tagged traffic. Aber
wie sagt man ihm denn jetzt, dass er ein VLAN...
anlegt?
So, wir sind dran über
Port SFP2
sind wir dran, ne?
Wir sind dran über
SFP...
SFP2. Okay.
Was?
Modestrict?
VLANs? Wie addet man jetzt hier was?
Wo ist hier denn
ein add-Knopf? Ach, append, oder was?
Alter!
Append! Jetzt ernsthaft?
Hätte man das nicht add nennen können?
Append!
Das ist ja die ppp-geilste
Bezeichnung, die ich dafür je gesehen habe.
Okay.
VLAN-ID 420?
Members?
Was? Was ist das für ein Scheiß?
Das sind das hier die Ports, oder
was? Hat das
der Praktikant mit jQuery
gemacht, oder was?
Apply. Excellent.
Okay, strict packt er mich
immer da rein. Das bringt mir jetzt ja
nix. Da bräuchte ich ja ein zweites Gerät,
wo ich das noch
mit reinpacke.
Was ich jetzt nicht hab,
aber okay.
Okay, aber da komm ich dahinter. Ist auf jeden Fall
nice. Was kann man bei ACLs machen?
Append. Appenden kann man schon mal.
Ah, das ist so
Port Security Lite, oder was ist das?
Account S... Alter, was ist
das für ein GUI?
Ne, das ist nicht mal Port Security Lite.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Na doch. Ich kann sagen,
es muss die MAC-Adresse
dahinter sein. Okay, dass das funktioniert.
Boah, aber das GUI
ist nun wirklich schon echt Painschamp.
Richtiges Painschamp.
Ob der das auch kann?
Kein Schimmer. ACL.
Append.
Ne, ich glaub du kannst...
Account S? What the
fuck?
Mirror 2. Okay, man kann den Port spiegeln.
Redirect zu
Port.
Okay. Ne, man
kann anscheinend bloß Sachen
blocken. Man kann anscheinend nur
Sachen blocken. Also, wenn dahinter
ein Gerät ist mit falscher MAC, dann ist
vorbei.
Ne, so viel kannst du da
wahrscheinlich nicht machen. Aber mal ganz im Ernst,
für einfache Sachen ist das ja vollkommen
ausreichend.
Aber, ist schon
ein bisschen wirr, ne?
Zumindest ist schon mal gut, dass man
das nennen kann. Dann nennen wir das mal irgendwie hier.
Uplink
SFP 1.
Oder was? Da wissen wir schon
mal...
Da wissen wir schon mal, was Sache ist.
Und das wird mal...
Also, das wird Uplink SFP 1
und das hier wird...
Das hier wird...
Tja...
Desktop
SFP 1.
Letztendlich. Also, so werd ich das ganze
aufteilen.
Die Firmware ist crap, aber
für 85€ ist wirklich nice.
Da kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Also, von der Idee her will ich das so machen.
Das gibt den Uplink zu meinem Ubiquiti
10G Switch im
Serverraum hinten. Hier kommt mein
Desktop dran. Und die
können eigentlich so bleiben. Hier kommt alles andere.
Ich werd da auch WLAN-mäßig wahrscheinlich
nix großartig machen erstmal.
Was aber cool ist,
ich könnte mir zum ersten Mal
beispielsweise das
WLAN, wo die ganzen Access Points
drin sind, an Desktop holen damit.
In irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Die sind glaube ich auf Hochtouren
gerade am Programmieren, was Firmware angeht.
Werde ich dann morgen mal anschließen.
So.
So, Leute. Ich hoffe...
Oh, da frage ich noch.
Hat euch
der Stream gefallen?
Ja, ja, ja.
So.
Ähm...
Was ist das? Das ist ein 3D gedruckter
Keks.
Exzellente. Stellen wir jetzt hier hin.
Ja, der ist...
Das ist nicht ganz original Keks.
Man sieht es ja hier.
Da fehlt ja was hier.
Da fehlt was.
Kein original Keks.
Ja. So.
Nice, Leute. Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Rollo W. Dankeschön für den
Primesub. Wir gucken jetzt mal in den Chat rein.
Fällt mir gerade ein. Habe ich ja noch gar nicht gemacht.
Was habe ich denn hier vergessen? Chat.
Cute Chat. Wo sind wir?
Eieiei. Das kann ich mir doch jetzt nicht alles angucken.
Okay. Also fangen wir mal
von unten nach oben an.
Ja, der ist nice.
Der ist nice. Dann habe ich... Ne, ich habe den Hex
PoE. Ich habe nicht den Hex S.
Ich habe den Hex PoE.
Echt? Schafft der? Schafft der
keinen Gigabit komplett? Also der Hex PoE
kriegt das ziemlich, ziemlich sicher hin.
Hast du da irgendwie viel Fireball
Regeln oder so drin? Weil ansonsten...
Zeig mal.
Ah, das ist die... Die ist alt.
Ich glaube, das ist der, der hat irgendwie auch nur ne...
Ne, ey. Das muss der packen.
Das muss der packen.
Äh...
Test Results.
Das muss der... Guck mal.
Der sollte, der sollte überhaupt
keine Probleme haben, dein Vodafone Zeug zu routen.
Aber absolut gar nicht.
Der kriegt da fast
2G da drüber.
Also das wäre... Machst du damit
irgendwie was Besonderes?
Weil der sollte, der sollte dein
Standard Gigabit Vodafone eigentlich easy
geroutet bekommen.
So.
Die Musik leiser.
Äh, ist zu spät. Aber ich glaube, die war echt
teilweise ein bisschen laut.
So.
Weil der
Raspberry definitiv maximal
synkt mit 1G.
Und der Adapter synkt mit 2,5G.
Das heißt, ich kann testen, ob die 10G Ports
auch mit 2,5 gehen.
Übertakten was sonst. Und RGB natürlich.
Jaja, 88
ist das Nazi-Netz. Genau.
Was machen denn alle, die 88 geboren sind?
Ja.
Deswegen setzt sich ja auch
im Consumer-Bereich so mit der Zeit
jetzt 2,5 und 5G durch.
Weil das alles
easy auch über ältere
Kupferkabel mit R45-Stecker geht.
Preislich ist 10G
daheim auch überhaupt kein Problem.
Doch, 10 Rules sollte der auch packen.
Es sei denn, das ist irgendwie was super kompliziertes.
Guck doch mal, ob der CPU-mäßig
am Limit ist in den Stats.
Heißklebe-Champ.
Nope.
Wie gesagt, vom Webman
halte ich gar nichts.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Alles PSSH und gut ist.
Okay, war ja nichts.
Also Leute, macht's gut.
Nicer Unboxing-Stream.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.